this is jaco podcast number 93 with echo
Charles and me Jocko we Lincoln good
evening echo good evening I was lucky
and blessed to have had the honor to
serve in the United States military
during the time of war I fought
alongside US Army soldiers sailors and
Marines on violent battlefields and I
saw with my own eyes my generation of
warriors uphold the proud tradition of
the American fighting man America's
military has a storied history of
bravery ingenuity and grit but it's most
important tradition is the tradition of
victory America's military wins Wars it
is as simple as that if our nation deems
it morally right and existentially
necessary that our military is
unstoppable
of course and rightfully so the credit
for victory is often given to the men on
the frontlines to those that are taking
the fight to our nation's enemies in
close combat that credit is
well-deserved but it is not the only
credit that needs to be bestowed because
it is a simple fact that many of the
most critical victories in America's
history were won not only on distant
bloody battlefields but were also won
right here at home
in factories fields and farms you see
our ability to produce to design grow
build and manufacture has been just
important to our nation's victories as
our ability to fight and throughout
history when Americans marched to war we
marched wearing boots made by American
hands and we wore uniforms that were cut
and sewn in factories like this one our
body armor helmets and weapons have been
the products of American work ethic
skill and determination the best planes
ships and vehicles in the world that
carry us to war and then support us on
the battlefield they only exist because
Americans built them without the
American worker there can be no American
soldier so let us never forget that the
freedom we cherish so dearly is a gift
not only from our American servicemen
and women but it is also a gift from the
American worker the American worker who
toils in fields in factories in
shipyards and on job sites
the American worker who gets up day
after day after day not only to build
and create products but also to build
our economy the strongest economy in the
world which gives us unmatched influence
and gives our great nation the ability
to make the world a better place with
that knowledge I could not be prouder to
stand here today and be a part of this
opening I could not be prouder to be a
part of this company origin which like
America itself will succeed because of
the power of the American worker they
will succeed because of the power of
American grit
an origin USA will succeed because of
the unmatched power of the American
Dream and I would like to thank all of
you especially America's workforce for
making this dream possible
and that is a speech that I gave today
in a town called Farmington Maine and I
was at the opening of the new origin USA
Factory
now as I've been saying we are now in
league with origin USA and tonight I
have with me our new partner and our new
friend Pete Roberts who as you will see
has shown some pretty incredible
fortitude in the business world and who
I believe is just getting warmed up
so mr. Pete Roberts founder of origin us
a black belt in jujitsu by the way and
also black belt in making things happen
welcome to the show man honored to be
here everything you just said man just
captures everything I feel in my heart
and mind for sure well in that speech
live was phenomenal you know it was
awesome walking around the factory and
meeting people meeting the workers here
I mean just we came in and Jill she was
she was it's a week of vacation what's
she doing she's in here working she's
working and you know just and I wasn't
even really didn't really know what I
was going to say but after coming up
here meeting her seeing the rest of the
people grinding to make this happen yeah
I realized that I realized exactly what
I was gonna say I was gonna talk about
the fact that literally men on the
battlefield you're you're you're
propelled there by American workers and
that's what this that's what this
represents and you know we'll get into
how all this kind of came together in
this
kind of perfect storm yeah we'll get
there but we'll get there in a little
while okay because first we got to know
a little about a bit about you and your
crazy ass which I say with all you know
in the most complimentary possible way
so tell us about just growing up like
get me from like birth it's a high
school what was that all about
absolutely so it all started in Sparta
I'm for real it's real Spartan blood
Korea yeah no my my what your what your
because Roberts isn't no Angela cuz I'm
Greek actually yeah mom's in it she's
quick
so I mean she's clearly Greek because
I'm never clearly a Greek and she made
that baklava today yeah no I thought she
might pull out a Spartan sword at some
point and like attack me yeah she's
pulled out a big thing of baklava yeah
and like sugar-coated I just don't care
did you feel guilty um no I wanted more
yeah how do you care what we like
where's all the baklava I'm like it's
God that I looked over there's six
pieces left I had four of them that's
awesome no I'm a half-breed just half
Spartan so no uh yeah man I mean like
the rest of America you know my my
grandparents immigrated from Sparta
Greece in the early nineteen hundred's
great gram lived to a hundred and five
legit credit yes yes mice mice even on
Jocko white TVs I'm going through it she
no she didn't need to be she had the
Mediterranean diet nice I even my son
got to meet her eyes she looked for a
long time but awesome yeah so from a
young age I got to see the American
dream from my mom's side of the family
you know
when we were kids I was born down
Massachusetts Gloucester and moved up
here when I was a young kid my mom
wanted to get myself and my three
siblings out of Massachusetts and into
the woods just because she saw some
shifts happening she didn't like so she
brought us up here and said make a go of
it basically and what what business or
whatever what to date what do you oh oh
I saw I got to see my my family build
some pretty pretty cool businesses down
in Massachusetts so being an
entrepreneur was something I always
admired but didn't realize I wanted to
do that until a little later in life but
my my my family down there my
grandfather had a sub shop you know
super-soak for those of you I don't know
there's that's one of those things where
they call it different things across
America yeah a sub in New England is the
same thing as a Subway sandwich rivet
also in New England you call it a
grinder do you call it a grinder a
grinder would be I think technically oh
no that's not a hot sandwich that's
hoagie oh yeah hold more boy that's
another one a poor poor boy you know
another word for it so sub ya sub so you
so granddad on the sub shop a few a few
subs was very successful with the
sandwich making nice I got to see that
my cousins built a big multi
multi-million dollar company and I and I
had to watch this from away because I
moved up to here to Maine when I was 8
years old so I wasn't cultured in that
at all in the business world I didn't
have anybody to teach me about business
and I just got to see it and not be
directly part of it which I always
wanted to be you know but I always
looked up to them and and and whatnot
and both from business perspective and
athletics you know they were very good
athletics my family and
and my uncles and cousins and stuff so I
looked from afar up here in Maine in the
woods in an old farmhouse down a dirt
road with no neighbors cows in a field
yeah that's where I grew up and then
high school you you said you were I know
you're athletic
wait how tall are you 6 3 and shrinking
6 3 ensuring can't man knows and what's
your max what's your what are you
walking around that right now right now
I can tell you exactly 250 3.0 yes but
you played what would you play I in in
high school three Sport athlete in
college football Division one for a
couple of years not the best experience
of my life learning experience but not
the best
well what why wasn't it the best
experience in your life I you know I was
I was real good at it football
I was not passionate about it but I
still worked my ass off because that's
the thing you were kind of even though
you would just be g OCH i was you were
also an artistic guy right artsy fartsy
i was an artsy fartsy kid i got along
with everybody the the jocks athletes
all the artsy kids you know I liked
everybody I could appreciate everybody's
talents were you like drawing painting
or me doing everything they have already
paintings go welding sculpting
everything just doing everything yeah
and tackling people yeah getting played
tight end it's were you more passionate
about art than you were about football
for sure for sure and so you're playing
football like it wasn't just one of
those things where hey I'm good at it
and I'm getting a scholarship so I'm
just gonna keep doing what I'm doing
yeah so back in 1997 Burke in the dirt
yesterday Oh Oh back in the day ya know
it was a back of the day as some will
remember hockey fans Maine's hockey team
was phenomenal they had the Korea kids
on there and they were that that team
took gifts and what happens when you get
gifts and people find out sanctions so I
went into college and they had like ten
scholarships so I didn't actually have
asked
oh ship to my second year of college god
I had to prove myself and I worked my
ass off and then I fell into the
politics of college football and I saw
the ugly side of the politics of college
football and well and what are you
talking about because I'm the only guy
sitting at the table that it apparently
play college football I was busy in the
trees yeah what do I mean what does that
consist of like you're trying to get to
be in a certain position starting or is
that what we're talking about let's say
like okay uh so I was supposed to I was
supposed to start my right eye red
shirted my freshman I was supposed to
start tight-end
got into a bar brawl mmm right and
during the summer couldn't play the
first few games and it was me and one of
one of my friends and we were both
freshmen and he was a big kid local kid
here they're playing in the NFL um and
we were kind of like fighting for the
first spot on the depth chart in a depth
chart for those of you who don't know is
like kind of where you stand right you
know and you see your name on there and
you see everyone else's name and you
want to be the top guy right so make
that out for every position oh yeah okay
oh yeah every position check yeah so a
little pressure to perform and I stayed
after my freshman I put on 27 pounds of
like hard earned muscle no illegal
substances squats McDonald's the squats
like don't eat some food at McDonald's
what did you what would you go from what
weight to what weight day I came into
college at like - it was like 200 in
like 225 and you went all this oh no ten
maybe okay nice cool and then yeah and
then just earned it earned it in the gym
I remember my tight end coach coming up
to me and saying hey you know Steve
Steve was his name he's like he's out
and he's like you're gonna be starting
this first game and I'm like shit I mean
I stayed I stayed like work my ass off
you know stayed during breaks and
everything and I was a good athlete yeah
and what's cool is yeah that you're
actually
going as hard as you can yeah that's
something you weren't even that
passionate or no but I committed to it
you just wanted to win yes yeah no I do
it okay you look at yourself in that
depth chart even if you don't
necessarily like what you're doing you
make the commitment and you drive and I
didn't want to be number two you know so
it's super competitive college sports so
anyways that my tight end coach like
you're starting the first game I'm like
yes call all my family call my friends
tell them what's up make sure everybody
has tickets yeah yeah Deana like a day
before the game the coach comes to me
and says Pete I gotta talk to you and I
said okay he's like I just got a huge
argument with a head coach and you will
not be starting in the football game I
said okay why he goes basically told me
politics my friend still a friend of
mine local kid he came in on a full ride
local kid big kid had probably a better
frame to build on and basically what the
even though maybe I you know it is
College we have different gifts the head
coach shut it down said nope he's not
starting my coach is like he should
start he's performing better you know
he's strong in the weight room
hand cleaning 300 pounds the kids ready
to go he should be starting I got a huge
fight almost got fired the coach of my
my 10th coach Thomas cup fired he said
you'll be playing a lot in the game
though but yeah he'll be starting guess
how much playing time I saw none zero
who
so that was the first game of the season
you said yeah and so then what happens
is you grind out the rest of the season
yeah man how's your attitude I worked my
ass off and to her you kept trying to
earn did you ever start here's the
shitty thing already sounded pretty
should be any action it's pretty shitty
dude here's the shitty thing man I
couldn't I'm telling you I had football
PTSD after this I didn't watch a
football for 10 years they put on
television I'd walk out other room I
just hang out do something else and
they'd be watching the games my son
loves football my father my family loves
football
I couldn't do it I had like a just a
version to the sport to make a long
story short nice it's been 45 minutes we
haven't even made it past shot how's it
my my scholarship the money like like
some of the money hit your account right
and like shit didn't kick in for like my
food and everything I'm like my coach
the head coach it was a narcissistic guy
love coming to the weight room and just
like waving his hair and you know one of
those guys yeah yeah yeah he's like yeah
I'll take care of it Pete it's fine
everything's happening okay week later
coach still this isn't you know I'm on
it I'm on it I'm talking with the ad
it's everything's good week later know
when coach it's still like man I'm
stressing you know like I'm gonna have
to get a job like what's up with with
this he goes I need to talk to you my
office said okay I sit down in his
office your scholarship money is not
going to kick in really I over gave
title nine had kicked in and he over
gave it now
is he being truthful with me or did he
find a new recruit
that was better mmm that he pushed me
out who knows
I don't know why cuz the kid behind me
ended up starting fullback the next year
right so maybe I got pushed out maybe he
over gave fact of the matter is that
bastard lied to me and didn't follow
through with his word and that will
never happen again
I will never surround myself with those
types of people and that lesson I carry
to this day I think about it a lot it's
one of those moments in your life that
kind of changes your life I said you
know I'm tell you something
I worked my balls off for you in this
program I'm ready and this is what I get
that excuse out out of the office I grab
my cleats ended it with my buddy Chad
Rogers and walked out the door and
didn't look back that was that it so
with that that was your sophomore year
yeah that would have been my red shirted
it was right after my sophomore year
yeah yeah so what are you studying
at this time studying uh new media which
was really new cuz he remembered the
internet hitting like 97 98 came hot
right really there's a date on that
ambiguous link you can call it 97 that's
when it became hot yeah for sure I think
so okay for sure for it that's what it
was like the Internet yeah everybody
meet everybody's hello well calm yeah
Netscape yeah but you know you could
really surf the web websites and stuff
yeah and website development and flat
this flash it came out media all the
stuff so anyways I was into that I I
discovered that the computer thing and
fell in love with design on the computer
and although I was a sculpture major I
used to weld up crazy-looking shit I
actually zippered the coal post dude I
did for like my final project you want
to know what I did I built this big
friggin zipper on
this like canvas and I erected it and I
zip it up the Pope I'm talking that the
like though like they're like a giant
real zipper real zipper that you know
like that thing that like the thing you
hold it yeah dude it was this big as if
my my my my art teacher they allowed you
to do that and have a choice I just went
out and did it
it's time yeah and would say like street
art and ski gorilla yeah it was weird I
think I got some of that frustration I'm
for sure bring it up yeah I have never
met anybody that do something might
might my did you get graded on it yeah
dude
so how did you not tell anybody because
what happened was as I erected it in the
practice field and my teacher she walked
over with me to look at it and she
looked at my shoes at a plus weight low
she you did it like you did in there say
hey look at this like what do you think
she goes she looked at me she goes what
she didn't think it was possible bro
when you said like eyes if my goal plus
I'm sitting here thinking what is this
some slang term that I don't know about
does that mean hang hanging toilet paper
off of it like what does this mean mean
zippering I wish I had a photo of it I
wish you did we didn't have digital
cameras back then yeah yeah but that
teacher was cool she was I remember her
name but she was crazy and you left it
up for the practice guys when they
showed up pull it down she she actually
told pulled me aside one time and she's
like you drive this class how what you
do and how you act everyone is gonna
follow basically she was she was pretty
cool but it was a I'll give you props
for that shit done zipper it you ain't
nothing at all is a goalpost called 30
feet probably more than like the full go
depends with the practice and we helped
you berries full zipper I am not even
kidding
put that I put in the in it and I and I
built it out of like wood laminated
bandsaw like all the lugs and I had that
fit together perfectly in that whole
zipper part had the zip
it was functional yes that's good I love
I told my teacher miles knew she's like
impossible could make it function okay
let's see yeah like I said it's
fortitude and I mentioned that earlier
so at this time
what are you what's like going on
personally personal life do weren't you
still in high school sweetheart it was
yeah yeah so I my wife Amanda my bride
we got together we were sixteen fifteen
sixteen through through a difficult
situation we became friends and we've
been together ever since they were drawn
together by a difficult situation and
you stayed together through college
absolutely and she wasn't looking at you
like like I need to get away from this
guy yes zipper horse you know she she's
very understanding apparently yeah yeah
you know the corny line like you
complete me like she I tell people like
she if my glass is a little full she
just dumps him out and if it's running a
little dry she puts it back in buzz so
and she always has you know what I mean
so she's brutally honest and you know
just might my soulmate no that's awesome
that you guys were you know I knew that
but it's kind of cool that you guys stay
together all that time now back to your
your major and now your sir not playing
football you're sitting there in college
you're studying new media which no one
knows anything about I didn't even know
anything about it and we actually hired
the professor's my class really we had a
big committee of students and we hired
the freaking professors and so and so
then you're learning how to do what
build websites
yes that's like this you're learning
things like it's been all like the first
software hit you had like this Maya and
you could do 3d animation they built
like Toy Story in Maya or something yeah
yeah you had like mmm flash Macromedia
remember the flash websites all the
animation yeah stuff like that so we I
learned about that so how did you make
the jump from that to going into
business in that
Arina I was good at it and I was
passionate about it and what happened is
my sophomore year after I got done
playing football I went right to a
marketing agency sold myself on the spot
and got hired on the spot and I became
their lead web developer and you're like
19 I was 19 with blond hair nice yep
they were like who is this kid for the
record when I was 19 I had blond hair to
go get it yeah that's cool well a lot of
Hawaiians have blond hair so 19 with
blond hair yeah man I walked in and I
just sold myself okay so then how did
that morph into your own business yeah
so I I wasn't here in a cush job I take
if you're the lead 19 years old Chris
job at 200 bucks a week buddy Rankine
which I need was pretty legit for you
though right yeah because it was either
that or the YMCA yeah you know and I did
work at the Y but uh yeah I mean it was
I I cut my teeth at this ad agency where
I learned from this really good graphic
designer Brad who started his career
doing pay stop so paced up is like when
you're designing an ad you actually have
to take an exact so all the little tools
you use when you're in like Photoshop
and other programs those are real tools
real life tools so he'd take like the
knife and he cut around the picture and
then they'd put that and then like the
typography and so I cut my teeth under a
real designer not many people get that
anymore so I learned from a master of
design and how long did you stay at that
at that agency Vinc I was there till I
was 19 20 21 three years I think and
then I then I moved back and I start my
own company here and that was just in
Sparano
what made you say you know what but you
must have seen a pathway at the agency
my to to take over or not even take over
but just to move up the chain of command
and get paid more than 200 bucks a week
and all that I did what in your brain
clicked were you like you know what I'm
not working for the man yeah absolutely
I'll tell you that I got to go back to
give you that though raking blueberries
and throwing hay mm-hmm manual labor
throw hay for a day and get a $10 bill
you're gonna work very hard not to do
that
raking blueberries in Maine which is a
staple of us menas that's tough work
you're bent over in the Sun in the
blueberry fields and guess what you do
for your first week you earn your rake
so was that mean there's a different job
that they give you the rake picking oars
and you've got a body that you've got a
body you're in debt
you're usually the rake and you have to
work it off how much you think that rate
cost uh I'm doing the math I'm like it's
like this is tough but I like it yeah so
when I when I walked into my interview
at this marketing agency this kind of a
pompous uh you know kid I said he said
what do you want to do long-term mark I
said starting up my own business I'm
gonna own my own business
mhm he goes you don't want to do that
you do not want to own your own business
you know you don't know what it takes to
survive in a world of business and I
said okay proceed then I learned and
suck the knowledge I could all the
knowledge I could I just sucked it and
sucked and sucked it and then I moved
home and started and what city was at it
I started well I started the business
out of my college apartment I was about
as big as his table
I was the man though I had a little a
Mac the black one of Wall Street that
would that was there was a mouse called
Wall Street it had like a it was black
and I had like a rubber on the sides mmm
you know what I mean that so you were
the man yeah that you and I think that
thing caused me some issues because it
was very tough to have kids I set that
thing on my lap for hours on end and I'm
telling you something with radiation man
I had to practice a lot to have kids
practice was good but it got a little
tough when it we can't have kids so but
uh yeah man I started the business out
of my college apartment my first insight
new media marketing agency a new media
company and just started hammering and I
was fearless going after accounts and
clients you know and two years later I
find myself in Park City Utah sitting in
the front of the president of Rossignol
Quicksilver selling him an idea like
Bill Gates I didn't exist yet mmm
and telling him what I could do and then
they gave me the money to do it and then
we did it and the rest is history
so ever till the recession so everything
was rocking and so did you so you were
in your college apartment but then
where'd you end up I ended up here in my
hometown and you had space you got an
office in all nine yards yeah well I
started in a barn and it was me and
another guy my first hire and then we
moved into kind of like a like a
double-wide trailer house you know we
call it a double-wide did have a skirt
yeah yeah yeah okay right that's the
vinyl skirt you kidding me who doesn't
have a leather skirt to keep it real so
we went there and then we moved into a
basement in town this is like the
perfect progression right yeah and then
we hired a few more and then we moved
into a beautiful we had built out a
studio where man it was on we actually
designed it because you were making
legit money now we were how many boys
are we talking about I think maybe seven
or so no kind something like that and
now you're 22 yeah yeah yeah Julie to
get me two years old yeah six employees
yeah custom design office and we did
everything you want to hear something I
didn't know if I should say this are you
ready for this you may have to edit this
out I handled two governor's campaigns
in Maine twenty-two years old they
wanted like the best design the best
marketing so they came to
these youngins mm-hmm and we had this
one guy les Otten should maybe you not
say the name you who it was in national
news sorry I got to you cut it out
understood
really so News they know it's national
news okay really nice guy right after
Obama's first term so les came and he
wanted us to handle his campaign and so
he wanted a logo that was circular like
Obama's logo and so we did a I designed
myself a circular logo which green and
blue very similar feel not even close to
the same but it was round and who had
done around logo at that time next thing
I know this thing ends up on CNN all the
national news stations and they have
like the two logos Obama's logo and less
is logo I just got it influx of emails
and phone calls people like rip because
remember how that first term for Obama
remember how hot that was remember how
do people negative where they were
negative on you because they were like
we ripped it off and I was like really
really so he was around don't make a
round logo yeah especially after the
first Obama don't use circles don't use
sir that's that's don't for circles
so anyways it was it was it was an
interesting time there's a little bit of
stress did he catch heat for it
obviously I guess yeah yeah cuz no one
really cared that you know don't even
knew there were like some he was like oh
my added you hate just he made it up and
I thought it was great no well he you
know what they you know kind of a little
bit he did that but he had an advise
advisor then said this is the right
direction and whatnot so it was it was
interesting time so what was the heat to
her that he was like national media like
ripping you down people digging down who
designed it like one company that
designed it and just like Harry you all
they found you yearbook pictures like
Obama was like 15 days of like holy shit
like are we gonna survive this as a
company you know and
we did yeah yeah and so you you survived
that yeah and I guess your lesson is
like from that that you can't survive
things you're gonna like like it's
interesting I just caught that you said
15 days yeah because guess what
15 days no one cared anymore is that
pretty much pretty much yeah yeah I see
that a lot in the news you know people
simple freak out about something and I'm
like yeah I wait oh yeah wait a week
form for days and sometimes anymore
there's like some other meteor that hit
the satellite thing or whatever so you
know it was it was interesting you know
we were young you know in naive you know
I mean I think all entrepreneurs start
out naive honestly and from a leadership
perspective you're in a leadership
position yeah right for the first time
yeah and and you have a team of six
people you're the man yep and I'm
trusting you seen you say that with a
little hesitation yeah I trust that
people will do the right thing are the
people that are working for you your age
you know younger just just all the same
same age you're two different okay all
young so now you said recession what
happens there well we were we were kind
of like booming as a company building
some incredible now we would do an
interactive touchscreen kiosks and all
this really really cool shit but that
nobody was doing it the recession hit we
lost 65 percent of our business
overnight I mean what's the first thing
you cut in a recession advertising
you're not supposed to but you do the
wrong move but it's the move that
everyone makes that man I probably make
the same move there where can we cut
costs ad spend right stop that
anyways the recession hit and we had
built this company from like the ground
up just funneled the money back into the
company built built built by equipment
builders do do all this stuff I'm like
oh shit first time I thought about like
these guys bought houses here have
families are starting families moved
away how long had the run been at this
point this had been
there's a 5,000 that's a good question
when does the recession eight or nine
this is six seven-year run okay so yeah
these guys had established their lives
they established their families up here
yes they you were the for the form of
income you're how they're paying their
mortgage absolutely and I felt that you
know I don't know if that's weakness but
I'm sensitive to that man I that if I
promised somebody something like this
company is your future I mean this
company is your future I will stop
taking a paycheck and that's not the
right thing to do you gotta always pay
yourself right I will stop taking a
paycheck
to make sure you get yours that's what I
did and what I also did is I took out a
line of credit it was the first money I
had taken out from the bank ever and I
used that money to keep things going to
try to get through the recession but I
didn't want to lay anybody out what I
had them do was I had them start
designing in-house because by the way
the next thing that you do after you cut
advertising the biggest cost to just
about any business there is is you
people people so that's the next thing
that gets cut but you're saying you're
not gonna do that and I'm and I'm young
yeah in learning about business as I go
you know so no I'm not gonna do it now
they some of them bought houses and
stuff you know like I'm not taking away
their livelihood you know I'll find a
way to just get through right you know
and I and I believe I had the fortitude
to get through you know but
and there's the but they didn't and
here's why because I had them start
working on these how in-house projects
and I was training jiu-jitsu at the time
and so I was going to develop a platform
so that an academy could build a website
based off of a templated system for
their jiu-jitsu school and it was going
to be badass and we had done this for
like rossignol and dynastar we had we
were like one of the first companies to
build online tools to build things makes
sense mm-hmm there's a night in early
2000 so go on and you look at some
thing you wanted there's a little
customization that can be done to it you
guys that design things to move the
mouse around and yeah there's a bunch of
those now but has a bunch of there was
none of them okay with zero and so we
started building this thing and you're
you're building this thing but you're
not being paid for yet because
eventually going to sell it so you're
just that's a human i in-house project
is it out of me now did jujitsu take a
little bit more of my time than it
should have you know these things happen
you know did I think about it more than
anything else in the world I did and
just real quick how did you get into
jujitsu
well after football I stopped playing
football and I was like man I I need to
fight mmm like I need that you know I
always had this desire to fight maybe
all men have that I don't know but I
felt like many extra like extra like I
need to fight so I'm like Taekwondo
so I started fighting in Taekwondo and
achieved that in about two years it was
like okay now what and then I found you
Jitsu and I got choked out by 150 pound
kid and I was 285 pounds mm-hmm and I
was like that's a convince er I mean
couldn't figure it out I came at him
with every bit of athleticism the kid
choked me out almost cold yeah I had
what just happened and I bought into it
so anyhow anyways I I was passionate
about jiu-jitsu and I want I had this
perfect plan to build this system and
they started getting salty about it now
is that because they felt like there
wasn't income is because they weren't
getting paid by the project getting
commissioned or something like that what
were they gonna talk about they all got
salaries so what were they getting salty
about the fact that they were working on
my pet projects those words my pet
projects they were also salty I had two
very young kids and my wife in the
office but the kids were in the office
and they were you know playing with
their stuff and doing what kids you get
there being kids my company my office
my kids okay they found that a problem
so out of the main what was your
relationship because this this I'm just
assuming right now that you got a bunch
of people that are working for you that
are around the same age as you yeah and
so I'm guessing that you were kind of
growing out when we were super Bros a
super bros super immature bros mature
the immature kids right talented
immature kids I mean you're talking
about like hey let's shut it down and go
snowboarding we got two inches of
pow-pow on sugar low you know and we
need to hit that that's what we do we
just shut it down grab the snow bo
Rossignol would send us like ten
thousand dollars in product we just we
just go up we don't just rip rip on the
mountain hey man just get the work done
you know you need yeah it meant no
worries just do just make sure the works
done yeah
very loose super bro super bros yes
hitting the pow pow the powder so yeah
man the relationship was not a boss
worker employee relationship it was a
creative I always wanted to we had a
foosball table in the in the you know
give me a break
no this is a creative agency yeah yeah
yep but when shit hits the fan the
fingers go to one person this guy right
so alright I'm ready to sustain this
thing and make it happen they weren't so
one day I'm in my wife's office
and the whole crew gets up and hands me
a paper it's a thick paper they're like
we'll see you on Monday to talk about
this because they thought they weren't
expendable okay so they're giving you an
ultimatum ultimatum I was like I turned
white for a second I was like okay and
they walked out were you did you
anticipate this at all
no no idea I will never be caught off
guard like that again
it's gonna sting I was gonna leave a
mark
this is this a mutiny you know that's it
are you straight up me straight up
mutant yep okay
my wife is an emotional being we sat
down and we read this this paper and it
was a list of demands a list of demands
about profit sharing how the company was
making all this money and it wasn't
being filtered down to the employees and
about my kids and how they cannot come
into the office anymore because they
make noise a whole list of demands they
can't concentrate when they're playing
foosball yeah and and yeah
amongst other things young stupid kids
yeah and I was one of them yeah cuz I
was naive so we started looking at this
thing and I was just like wow it's I can
punched in the face and my wife went and
she spun up and shoe she's
french-canadian and she's she's you know
yeah anyway she's spun up I said okay
did she speak French when she's angry
no okay I wish that was kind of hot
could you speak French just make her mad
so she could yell at you and yes yeah
yeah no so so what we did is we just we
sat there and looked at each other and
we're like what what and I said do they
have any idea we just took out a line of
credit to support this place to get
through the recession do they have any
idea we don't have any work so what do
we do recon we opened up their computers
logged in and started looking for all
the interaction between the staff and
wow what they thought of me I was sad I
was like wow this is sad made me feel
like shit what they think I mean they
thought I was like some type of miser
like like squirrel away cash and Reis
well yeah because I because I was I
always kept a straight face have a happy
personality and they had no idea how
much in the hole we were yeah and I can
imagine that you're trying to actually
protect them from the stress business
yes and in doing that you didn't
communicate to them what was actually
happening which meant that they created
what was happening in their own minds
which was obviously with that shit them
creating what they think reality is in
their minds when they don't know all the
facts there's so many times in
businesses when I talk to businesses and
businesses are going through transitions
or there's something happening and you
know they'll they'll be asking like well
do you think we should tell you know the
employees what's happening right and I'm
like well you have two choices you can
tell them what's happening or they're
gonna make up a story to make up a story
and it's not gonna be good
they're gonna think worst case scenario
and so the open communications that is
what is how you prevent this kind of
thing and obviously you're 22 years old
that's pretty awesome that you were in
the position you were and obviously can
look back now and it's pretty simple to
see what the solutions were one of them
you were you were growing out with these
guys too much and this is a fine line
you know because you know in a CEO
platoon
I had bros lifetime brothers yeah that
were you know three or four ranks below
me but they were professional and they
understood the line between and they
understood and they respected the
position and and then there's other guys
that were you know that same rank lower
rank that I could knit couldn't give
that kind of closeness to and so that's
one of those things that you know we
talked about a lot with companies is
it's different for the different people
in your company so I'm not saying you
can't bro out with people and also that
doesn't mean you don't have awesome
relationships with your people because
that's what you want you want to have
awesome relationships with the people
that are working for you because they're
gonna do that much more for you and you
can do that much more for them and it
becomes a functional winning team
because everyone cares about each other
exactly there's a dichotomy there you
know are we being there's a lie are we
super bros what is that
what is that line that line is the thing
that you need to figure out what makes
it really hard with the relationship
piece is that it's different for
different people and I had some guys
that was an e5 and a seal platoon and I
was the lieutenant and they were my
total bros and there's another guy
that's knee five and I got to keep a
little bit distance just so they make
sure that they they stay professional
right and so this is this is challenging
stuff and great lessons learned for
anyone running a business especially if
you young people but it's not just young
people because I see seasoned CEOs
asking these same coin don't learn this
shit in college I'm sorry you know like
being an entrepreneur businessman or
woman whatever it's learned you know you
may have a gift of something or
accounting you may be a good salesperson
or good at marketing or something
nobody's born with a gift could be an
entrepreneur you know it's built it's
crafted over time and you have to fail
and fall flat on your face and get
punched in the face to figure it out
yeah so but what's good is unfortunately
there's those like those lessons that
your parents tried to teach you but you
didn't listen to and they taught me I
was so stupid if you're even aware of
them and that's what's good about like
someone that's hearing what you're
saying right now they they might not
recognize it before and this is a
chapter in extreme ownership right
dichotomy of leadership and you got to
be you can't be so close to your people
that one's more important we go through
this right but the awareness of it is it
gives people a percentage chance of
maybe instead of falling flat on their
face maybe they just stumble and they're
able to recover right so this is you
know classic I fell flat yes dude it
hurt too okay so what happens so I was I
was sad man at first then I got angry
and then I got even no no I basically
what it was is we are not expendable
heed these words and these demands and
we'll talk to you Monday morning okay
so what happens we do a little recon get
into the computers see the communication
between all of them what they thought
about me what they thought about my wife
what they thought was going on with the
company half an hour later I'm in my
vehicle divide and conquer
you're not going to tell me because in
that paper said do not come and see us
individually do not seek us out do not
try to separate one of us and have a
conversation and that's exactly what I
did by the way from the employee
standpoint this is a horrible move they
are making do as bad of a mistake as you
were making as a leader because what
they should any one of them could have
done is said Pete bro I gotta talk to
you man let me tell you what's going on
yeah this is what we're thinking we
don't know what's going on with the
company you got us working on these
random projects that are like your
projects we should be working for other
companies can you tell us what in God's
name is going on so we can move forward
that's what one of those nobody was that
mature and you could have brought him
into a room and said hey guys I
apologize for not telling you but let me
tell you what what income we have on you
know what next six months nothing
nothing
so this is what we're gonna do to try
and survive you could give him the plan
they would understand why you were doing
what you're doing anymore and it
would've been good so both sides of the
chain of command there are actually
making grievous mistake sad mistakes my
and I learned from that that that was I
mean I'm a transparent person as it is
you can ask me anything you want and I
will answer it I was just a dumb kid
though I didn't want to show weakness to
them is what I was thinking right
because I didn't want them to feel like
they needed to go find another job I
didn't wanted to think that Startalk
like all the company's gonna shut downs
making my own stories I didn't trust
they would make the right decision if I
told them this so I just carried on to
try to push through and you're right it
was a mistake to not share it with them
because it would have been I was we were
bleeding as a company but they were in
the blood I was trying to keep in it
would have been easier just to let them
decide what they wanted to do after in
hindsight telling them where we were as
a company how the recession had affect
but I didn't yeah and so I divided and
conquered a meaning I got my carnal
drive to the first one's house knock on
the door John we're gonna talk or you
have no job John's still with me right
now he works for origin I was pissed I
was so pissed I was crying a little bit
most best you were been so pissed like
you're just like you cried yes
negative next question really I don't
know even your kid will be oh yes I
guess I guess I'm grounded by being a
seven
I'm talking like 20 what am i 23 24 so
I'm like yeah yes I was in the teams at
that point what yeah crying okay it's
not echo I'm having a conversation it's
Oh piss you like started crying
honestly crying is not like anger does
not lead to tears in my in for me mine
is weakness leaving the body okay I get
it but being angry that's that's okay
but you know everyone's a little there's
a kid yeah yeah I was a kid yeah yeah
you remember I didn't have I didn't have
a mentor either like when I was a kid I
didn't have a I had I had one mentor my
friend my buddy's father because it was
a single single mom who was yeah it just
we barked as kids we a lot of the time
we raised ourselves I'd have a mentor
never like a father figure around all
the time to see how to so I just I I
worked off of pure drive and emotion
yeah yeah and again I'm not trying to be
a jerk you know I'm having fun with it
yeah absolutely
but so you're so you're so pissed soap
is you've got freaking tears in your
eyes yeah and you go to Johnny you
fucking you want this job or not because
if you say no you're not talking to me
you do not have a job and you've got a
new house
okay so he had he's in the car okay one
down one one in the game still in one of
the game got it as I drove to the others
houses they either didn't answer the
door and hid or answer the door and said
I can't talk to you and closed it
okay our kids you know does these are
kids which is a which is a message to
everybody yeah when you don't want to
talk to somebody you're not solving
anything you don't mean you don't yes
now now I'm not saying that there's some
times where I'm so mad at you that I'm
like Pete come back tomorrow bro cuz
right now
I'm gonna go good yeah I'm so mad I
could cry yeah something like that
sounds really do actually do that that
is a weak but that is that the point is
though seriously if there's if there's a
problem and you're not gonna talk about
it you're gonna sound like that kid
right there that answers where I can't I
can't talk to you right now fuckin shuts
the door that's that not a way to get
anything solved are there times where
you need a little bit distance yeah
because you're hot-headed yes that
happens as long as you know you're gonna
miss you both know that it's solvable
you know like I feel like with respect
to business and stuff like like if
you're working with a client you may
like bang heads with a client and be
like alright listen we need to we need
to shut this down and discuss it like in
48 hours that's learned over time not
when you're a kid you just want to get
after like even your approach was super
hardcore and this is an again you know
people a little bit aggressive yeah
people people want to hear me say like
that's right you go in and you say you
either talk to me now or you don't have
a job yeah
that I was already bleeding though so
was that the right choice I don't know
but the the approach for me would be
like hey let me explain to you what's
going on and then you can think more
about your decision because right now
I'm telling you what you've decided and
what you've presented me is so far off
base yeah that if this is what you want
to make your decision based on I'm
telling you what I'm gonna have to do is
let you go yeah because I haven't told
you yet
but we don't
any money and I'm paying you out of my
own pocket right so if you don't like
that and you don't want me to pay you
out of my own pocket over anymore I'm
actually good with that but if you want
to have a job and you want to try and
make this thing work let's have a
conversation and that's close to exactly
what I would say now yeah exactly 100%
the reason I'm making this point is I
had a guy hit me up on social media the
other yeah yeah so legit question he pre
prefaced the question he says I'm a very
direct guy like you meaning he's direct
like me okay and he says and I give
feedback and it makes people mad it rubs
them the wrong way and I'm just you know
I wrote back I go look man I'm direct on
Twitter which is 140 characters and I'm
a man answering 720 questions in you
know rapid-fire and and so yeah I'm
direct when someone says what is your uh
what is your average daily diet consists
of steak expert you know what I mean but
you're correct you're not an asshole
there's also like I'm having fun like
that'sthat's the fun part of you know
interacting with people through social
media that's not how I'm treating
another human being face to face in a
real relationship when we're trying to
build something then I'm using tact I'm
using maneuvering or manipulating the
situation I'm setting things up I'm
being the most tactful person in fact
not only am I not gonna rub them the
wrong way I'm gonna rub them in a very
nice way so they feel good about the
conversation that we had disarmed them
and the point is is that you know you're
you you like you said the what my little
quote was is what you would say now back
then you're young
you're bleeding I'm bleeding you're
pissed off yeah and you say you know the
wife's nagging at me about finances yeah
you know how that all builds two young
kids don't sleep through the night you
know it's it gets it gets tricky and
you're trying to maintain this so so
just FYI that what you just said you you
just said you know how it is and to be
honest with you I don't know how that is
because I was in the military I got a
paycheck every two weeks yeah I had kids
I had health insurance taken care of
I had a house taken care of it's it's a
huge it's it's actually a feeling
I don't know um so I yeah
don't know that feeling oh my I can only
imagine I can only imagine what I would
be thinking if I was in your shoes at 22
years old with a wife two screaming kids
and I don't have any money so yeah check
okay and get some I will tell you about
that feeling it's a feeling I'm never
gonna go back to as we as I divided and
conquered it did not go my way so
meaning that any people were saying they
can't talk or they hit and can't talk to
you they went they left their hot on
their homes whatever so I made a
decision what to do what don't talk to
my wife she's like what are we gonna do
I said well I said they all think
they're expendable except they're not
because there's not a person in this
world that is so good
oh they think I'm next right you guys
got him God they think they're not
expendable there's not a person's world
that is so good at their job but they
can't be replaced
mmm did you hear that echo yes they're
just just saying almost none but there's
a lot of talented people in the world so
what did I do
hefty trash bags get some I went up to
that studio and I scraped their desks
individually into trash bags and it felt
good I didn't even mean to say that like
but it felt good yeah I literally just
scraped it tied it up went to the next
one my wife just pushed it all into the
bag you know we dragged all the shot I
didn't care what was in the bag I don't
care what they had on their desks my
property your shit in the trash bags
didn't organize nothing is scraped
dragging them down the stairs gently
because I'm getting the feeling this was
not as you're not
dragged them down the stairs we were in
this this like studio you know third
floor studio that we had built out for
us
beautiful right that Monday morning the
art director who I cut my teeth with
came down he lived in Bangor Maine we
say Bangor came down and we were sitting
there and it was a glass like the class
and it's like you could see through it
being inside but from the outside you
can they all got out of the same vehicle
kind of giggling and chuckling like they
own me they own this company and they
walked in the door and there we were
sitting there with the trash bags and
they went from giddy to guilty to
sadness and their faces turned white
there's your shit take it and that was
it done
mmm-hmm that was tough I said a few
words but I was not going to be held
hostage to this situation in business I
say you've got like 40 years of being a
maker I did a speech recently at an
innovation for I wrote a speech for an
innovation Expo zero to twenty year
learning 20 to 60 year doing and 60 to
80 hopefully you're enjoying the fruits
of your labor anything good in life
takes ten years so my first 10 years had
passed but I still had 30 to go and so I
knew I wasn't done but the pain of the
situation in the in the experience I
grew exponentially overnight
we had salvaged a small part of the
company which was a was this we called
it web wear right it was like online
software like everything is now like the
cloud but there was no cloud
there was this system I was able to
salvage that because it had like a cool
little customer base of some high-end
customers and they paid monthly
it was just like reoccurring payments
right just to use it and so I found a
buyer for it and the negotiation to the
long time and in that long time we had
no income no money and so what did I do
I started selling shit dirt bikes
four-wheelers snowmobiles every
non-essential item I owned got sold
trying to maintain keeping my home right
which we had built my wife and I in the
forest which was our dream home just a
tiny little 1500 square foot timber
frame borrowing money from family and in
our parents and them knowing the
situation we're in so them actually just
like giving us food or whatever that
whole time I had to maintain like this
super composure to try and sell this
thing all this shit happening in the
background and I think it was like eight
months and I finally sold it two hundred
thousand dollars I think it was which
was cheap
for what we had built extremely cheap
but I was in a position where we had
nothing left and freakin nothing left
you know it was super super challenging
and I could have easily easily turned to
substance abuse which I didn't I've
never been into substances I could have
easily just fell off the deep end and
felt like a failure which I knew I
wasn't my wife wanted me to go find a
job she's like that's what I was about
to say I can't normal normal day you go
get a nine-to-five actually I can't do
this I can't do this Pete I can't do
this during that eight months then
you've gotta figure something I said
babe I will find a way to make this work
and I believe everything happens for a
reason it happened for a reason and I
just kept that in the back of my head
and I pushed and pushed and pushed
forward and it wasn't freaking easy like
it was super super hard like on us but
she stood by me unwavering she stood by
me never once did she want to leave did
she not believe in me or not trust me
which is what I needed and like I said
earlier about filling the glass back up
it was empty it was bone friggin dry
bone dry
and she just put a little bit back in
and we kept moving and kept chugging now
during that time period where you're
looking to sell the old company are you
hatching plans
or is you got to be 100% focused on
Giselle Moscow my creativity douve to
the bottom of the ocean done I was I
don't I've never experienced depression
you know but I get it I felt a little
bit like a failure I felt a little bit
like a failure but I knew I wasn't so
every time I had a negative thought I
would just push through it I just pushed
through the thought and what got me
through a lot of that was training
jiu-jitsu where I could expel my energy
and use my creativity which I thought I
had lost in jiu-jitsu it's a very
creative sport art and that kind of kept
me I guess I kept those endorphins
flowing so I could maintain some
stability but tactically your focus is
cell it's gotta gotta make it look good
let's show them the numbers that are
coming in for our few clients and a lot
of projections could be if that's all
you're doing yeah that's all you're
doing and you're thinking when you sell
that thing you're gonna have enough and
you'll figure it out later but you're
not worried about it right now exactly
so you make the sale I make the sale for
the first year we get a monthly check no
it's like five grand a month or
something not the full amount just like
five grand a month so during that time I
decided to just take 12 months and
figure out what comes next and in that
12 months I traveled around the country
training jiu-jitsu and filming a thing
we call BJJ weekly because that's what I
was passionate about and so we travel
around and film technique and train and
all this stuff and I was like an excuse
to Train jiu-jitsu that's it
this newsletter and after that 12 months
and traveling around and just
struck me what I wanted to do years
earlier I had designed this logo for a
ye brand off the cuff came to me I get
my ideas in the morning one morning I
sat down and just boom done five minutes
you know sometimes you can have a client
come in we used to and I spent 100 hours
on the frit and logo you know people
don't realize how much logos cost but
sometimes you just nail it like 10
minutes done finished it's just like
getting hit by lightning just boom done
and that's what happened with this
origin thing I wanted to start a brand
because what I had done and what I had
learned and over that year of driving
around and training and reconnecting
with myself and my family was that I
loved building brands and products I
loved taking something from nothing like
a drawing in making it into something
and I had an aversion to the screen and
in that space because of the new media
thing I was always on a screen and I I I
just I told the man I'd I need to like
do something physically like have
something physical and you'd have a
physical thing to do because I was in
our major and I'm an artist and I said
pop goal posts I need a thing to do so
in jujitsu I had seen that the uniform
like hadn't changed I don't know they've
been wearing kimonos for a thousand
years but you know judo you know
hundreds of years Jiu Jitsu 100 years
Brazil same thing same same damn thing
100% cotton uniform this is what you
wear I was like why why do you wear that
you got Under Armour with like wicking
stuff and you've got air helmets instead
of leather helmets and you know just all
these innovations in other sports and
jiu-jitsu had shit we had nothing like
wearing a bunch of just straight
cotton balls and you know sweaty soaked
in G that stretches and stinks bad it
sucked and so to start I was like okay I
gotta start I gotta start meeting you
you know the vision you see that G's
haven't progressed right you know that
they can be made better yep you but you
don't actually eat and so you say okay I
want to make of the best ghee in the
world yeah that's that's the vision yes
it is and you have to start somewhere
you gotta start somewhere so I didn't
know anything about textiles but I knew
about design and I knew about the human
body and you know how the human body
worked in in in college sports you
learned about that a lot you know
mechanics mechanics of the body uni they
retrain you how to run in college like
they you all run the same you do
exercises so you're all striking forward
striking with your foot you all run the
same and so I designed like Aggie pants
and it was like the cowboy cut because I
knew that in jujitsu when you like
you're squatting a lot and on your knees
and the material pulled up you're up
your leg but pull down your butt so you
like got plumbers crack which sucks so I
design like so the kneepads came up to
your hip so when you squatted it would
pull from your hips right instead of
across to the top of your leg and did
did some cool innovations like that and
then I was like all right time to go so
we launched a key yet we we we imported
this key from Pakistan one key I was in
the basement of my house and I was like
we're gonna start this brand so I hidden
the basement
sucked here comes the key we shot a
photo we saw some photos off it and I
launched it through BJJ weekly and boom
40 grand I was like wow but you didn't
have any geez
no none no keys but I wanted to prove
that we could do something different and
I trust it I could make it happen
knowing how many keys
I was like 200 years sold I've got
something here I've got something good
here and I knew a new adventure was
gonna start and my wife spun up in a
positive way no oh she just like what
are you doing I'm like I'm starting a
key brand and she like sick like I might
have a anxiety attack at first like you
Pete you you you can't do this again you
can't you know you can't start another
company you know it's like just and I
used this word lightly being around a
war hero like you know warrior here I
promise you that
PTSD of business right that's a real
thing like she she has she had like PTSD
of business because of what we had gone
through and selling everything and the
feeling you get that you keep you kick
and keep this feeling for me I used it
for Drive for her she used it for I
don't ever want to feel that again that
makes me like ill for me it was like I'm
never gonna feel that again I'm gonna
make sure I never feel that again and
I'm gonna do something about it so I did
it anyways started a company origin and
that's when it began 2011 10 2011 so how
do you start it so you've got one key
well you sold 40 grand worth of one key
that you didn't have right what what
sweetie do next
did you know at this point you wanted to
make him in America had you figured that
part out you know no I let me take my
figured you make him in America I
wouldn't want you to make them in
America and so I started like calling
all the factories and in Maine like hey
you know you guys so stuff yeah cool can
you saw this no okay
so Zeigler don't know main hazard
we had a lot of industry up here
manufacturing big time especially when
we when we were kids yes
you know big brands up here that build a
lot you know all kinds of stuff
vashu ten minutes away sold out
dexter shoe hayden shoe loo Hayden you
know San Antonio shoe passed away and
huge companies ll building new panels 20
minutes away so rich heritage
manufacturing but apparel and main a
little different we made shoes and we
wool fabric and stuff like that but
apparel wasn't wasn't the norm so what I
did is we were in that basement and
we're like okay and I just gonna make
this note that all those a lot of those
companies that you're talking about that
had built all this stuff here for all
those years a lot of them had left yeah
so that that's the local situation
except all of them had left l.l.bean
they still make some stuff here the rest
left gone so mounts don't make some
stuff here - yeah New Balance - oh yeah
for sure yeah New Balance is awesome so
I was like okay we're gonna make a belt
that's we're gonna we're gonna make a
belt Jiu Jitsu belt yeah yeah so there
was this guy in Lewiston who ran this
company and I called him up and like I
need some sewing machines he's like okay
well why don't you stop by in Lewiston
Maine one of the manufacturing hubs of
Maine at one time walked in he's like
what you need I was like this is what I
want to make it's a belt for martial
arts it's like okay and I said I just
need some machine to do that and like I
got 500 bucks cash I can spend on it can
you give me something to practice with
and so he sold me a machine showed me
how to thread the bobbin showed me where
when pull through the needle and I'm
like okay okay we filmed it so we knew
how to do it so we're like filming him
doing this like okay so he took the
sewing machine and then I put it in my
basement next to the desk and I'm like
that's so machine and my wife was just
like shaking her head luckily luckily we
had sold a pre-order so we had sold
40,000 dollars in G's that didn't exist
so she had gotten off my back
a little bit so that machinery sat there
and as we looked at trying to like make
this ski and I didn't say oh we're gonna
make Aggie in America I just said about
we're gonna make a key we're gonna
change the key mm-hmm we're gonna change
the key first so we we started the
import game everybody else is doing it
everybody's telling me manufacturing is
dead I did a few phone calls pretty much
everybody's like yeah you can't really
do that and so I was like okay you know
and the whole time I'm thinking like
something's not right here
that I can't do this and I just couldn't
put my finger on what it was so I
imported you know in 2011 and May we
started in 2011 and into 2012 did a few
batches to the whole you limited-edition
batch thing we're G's but we promoted it
with the innovations we had it was still
shit you know when it comes right down
to it what the key was yeah man it was
still shit it's still using old textiles
exist so you design the you said you
imported one from Pakistan yeah and then
what do you do like cut it up and
redesign it if somewhere did you send
the design to them and they so I I
design like everything in Illustrator
like a technically I want this here I
want the kneepads here they got a fall
here the you know belt loops because I
don't want it untie the baby all this
stuff and and then they and they send it
yeah done yeah okay finish so you know
you know in Pakistan
they're like the manufacturing for
martial arts it's like the manufacturing
hub in this little city called the sail
cot yeah they're actually like almost
like migrant workers as a ton of
factories jiu-jitsu factories but the
workers are the same oh the same guys in
they're all the same
they rotate around okay yeah hey we got
a contract over here we gonna make yeah
that's not my cookies a bunch of guys
show up there they work for pennies and
pennies yep yep so we did the importing
thing and we started to grow rapidly we
started to make money and at that point
my other business I was making kind of
monthly income and then I got kind of
like a chunk of money like a hundred
grand I was like all right cool I could
like take a deep breath and really push
this thing and sold I pushed it and we
started selling more and more then I
came out with this really cool backpack
called a mundial backpack new job
backpack technical backpack and we sold
a ton of them thousand of them and then
we came out with this product for grip
training and we weren't patenting
anything were just I was like boom
because that's what I did like once I
got on the roles like designed this
design and we were just selling selling
selling and during this time I was also
competing you know because a male say no
more it's jiu-jitsu and you want to test
yourself against the best in the world
so I was training hard I had ended up
winning the UM
let me do let me digress were said I had
seen another company release a product
for grip training that looked exactly
like ours what was the product that
you're training yeah it's called an
orangutan so it's you it's like a McGee
and then collar
yeah and it's like yeah it was cool it
was awesome and I was like those
bastards ripped us off but I wasn't
thinking my manufacturer or anything
about I'm psyched man come here
Christophe I should have patented that
you know blah blah blah okay so I was
competing I ended up going to Canada I
won the world Pro trials as a brown belt
at the time one of the world Pro trials
and the black belt division because they
you know they they put the divisions
together as you know for that was in
2012 now they think they separated him
but so I got to go over to Abu Dhabi and
compete in the world Pro and as a brown
belt in that black belt division I'm
sitting there before my match and I'm
supposed to fight Shan ji Ribeiro and
the quarterfinals of the open Division
three and I I'm gonna say this it was
bad seating like the seating of the
brackets was not good okay like I had in
my bracket a guy from Brazil JT Torres
Shan ji and maybe under a galvan and so
JT didn't want to fight so he so I
fought the other kid from Zil and he was
much smaller and I was athletic and good
and I ended up winning and then JT just
kind of like didn't want to fight so
then he coached me he can shine gee we
had a war it was cute man I had a last
couple of seconds pan is very close the
problem was no challenge a multiple time
world champion from the best of one of
the best of all time yeah in jiu-jitsu
yeah big-time awesome guys an awesome
awesome guy so but the seating was bad
like Lovato wasn't in it like there was
a couple other guys I know just if my
division could have been tougher and I
would have gotten my ass kicked a lot
earlier okay so but we had a war and it
was awesome and maybe I would have won
if I had worked harder or maybe I would
have won if that girl from Poland didn't
walk by me right before the match with
an origin Gyan and a different logo on
the back and what was on your cut of
Aggie like the ghee that you designed
yeah and you see a girl from Poland
who's competitive competing she walks by
yeah it was it was actually uh it was it
was a the pit the pants yeah it was the
panther there's a logo different logo on
the back but our
whole thing your design yeah looked of a
different logo yeah I knew it was my
manufacturer and then everything clicked
they ripped off the orangutan grip
trainers okay okay but what am I to do
because I'm locked into these guys now
so I had to strategize so I went out and
lost and the quarterfinals got on an
airplane worse freaking flight of my
life because I'm an ADHD kid and I can't
be stuck in a freakin seat for 14 hours
that sucks and on the ride back I was
talking to JT who I'd become good
friends with him he was kind of like in
a tricky position in life he was still
with his instructor in Maryland and just
didn't know kind of what to do he wasn't
progressing and he says he was telling
me like man I gotta I've got to get like
I have to do a full workout before I can
actually train with the guys cuz he was
so good he just wasn't getting in you
know and you know the mecca of jiu-jitsu
you know is California I would go so far
as to say San Diego San Diego that's
where yeah San Diego that's where he
went so he was figuring his whole thing
out SoCal for sure SoCal yeah yeah yeah
he was figuring his whole thing out and
I was I'm thinking about is like this
Robbie I'm like man I think I'm gonna
build a factory a war on the airplane I
was like he's looking at me like how
yeah on a pillow factory screw this shit
this is bullshit I said I'm not
competing anymore I'm done and all she
wanted to do is win the World
Championship so we kind of like helped
each other a little bit in that plane
ride back like tentative you know
bouncing ideas off each other
decompression decompression so I got
back and I Skyped my manufacturer and I
was like
over Skype I'm like this is bullshit you
freaking I didn't say that
so you fucking ripped off our
intellectual property and sold it to
other brands and he said business is
business
dang you ever have a defining moment in
your life where you just turn on and
you're like yep done I knew at that
moment what we were gonna do like it was
clear it became clear and I knew the
challenge in front of me
and I knew it was insane and I knew it
couldn't be done and I was like it's
happening props it's so so I got to tell
you a little bit of the what happened
right after right after that I went out
to the world championships to compete
because I had already signed up and that
was gonna be my year
we were there and there was this brand
there and I walked up and I walked by
and I I just double take I was like what
and I look for the right and there's our
mundial technical backpack right there
but with brain with sending their logo
on it I went up to the guy and I was
like dude I said got any original ideas
and everybody there's a badass except
for this guy who doesn't do jiu-jitsu
who does nothing right
just some chubby dude who wants to
capitalize on the success of combat
sports and jiu-jitsu growth in
California and I'm not gonna name the
company and I was like that is a week I
said in bullshit I said get some
original friggin ideas I went down
walked down and myself and the deco our
business partner and any his wife and my
wife were down there
and I told my wife in spin did she ever
she went up there and she flipped out on
the guy Amanda bringing it she's
bringing it 5 to 103 pounds a fury
french-canadian fury done it was awesome
we flew back and and the picture was
already clear this was just like added
motivation just added motivation I
called one of my buddies Tim and and
John was already working for me from my
last business the sole survivor
the sole survivor moved back to
Farmington what we did is we grabbed
that like that tape you put around trees
and you want to flag trees to cut mean
you gotta flag the trees to cut and we
kind of like our John I have seven acres
of property which is okay listen seven
acres is not a lot of property in Maine
you can buy property in Maine for five
hundred dollars an acre in some places
private sale so let's just make that
clear seven acres is not a lot but we
have seven acres of land in the woods
and so I like flagged out I'm like we're
gonna build a factory here we just
flagged it out like this and this is
based on the architectural design that
you're engineered put through for your
factory yeah I think a factory should be
about this big
this looks like a factory size so
awesome I called the buddy and he
brought his chainsaw over and they're
just like I let's just do it and we just
just started cutting trees my
father-in-law came over with a chipper
we chipped it out okay we stumped it we
pulled the stumps out we're pretty
resourceful up in here and maybe a
murderer Yankee ingenuity that term for
sure that happens
so what do we do we cleared it we did a
little bit of Earth work I got on the
compactor and compacted all the sand and
poured a slab had had some some guys
some company sorrowed a bunch of eastern
white pine and had my buddy built build
a barn factory barn and we just spent I
don't know eight sixteen eight hours we
slept in zero hours around the clock we
just built this thing from the ground up
myself my brother friends family and we
just we did it and we built it and we
stuck a sewing machine in there were
like what are we doing that's where it
began and and we you know the thing is
is like if you listen I'm I'm all for
planning I I like to plan the what's
gonna happen and I like to like you say
execute I like to execute that plan but
do it and I like to lead the plan and
I'm shitty when it comes to like I'm
always making sure everybody's living up
to their expectations like as part of
the plan if they bought into it you
better fully bought into it there's no
room for like slacking like if I'm
working till midnight you're working
till midnight right you're not leaving
so that's what we did and I'm a pusher -
you like a push push push
I'd like to see how much I can get out
of somebody to push them to their
potential and see where their breaking
point is so I can learn about the person
but also get the best out of them so we
did it we built a factory and that's
where it started so then comes - what
what's next sewing machines yeah and
sewing machines and some and started
looking for staff that knew how to sell
yeah exactly so we didn't have any
lights yet we had one sewing machine and
we're just like okay this is our this is
how you sew and I found this old-timer
bill who came down he's like explaining
the different types he's been in the
business for 40 years fixing sewing
machines
and he's just like you know in his
accent he's like you know you got that
we want a single needle machine and a
double needle when you've got the
locking stitch in a chain stitch and you
know all this stuff and I'm just like
whoa and so I just absorb key became
completely absorbed in that right
learning about sewing machines I learned
how to run them how to fix them what
they were good for the different types
of feeding you know all all everything
about sewing machines how's that cool I
know about sewing machines now I need
some fabric so I started looking for
fabric guess what
they don't make fabric in the United
States they don't make fabric that we
needed in Mexico they don't make fabric
in Canada shit they don't make fabric
for jiu-jitsu ease and I was like what
are we gonna do what would you do you
just built a factory and you have all
these sewing machines and what would you
do
so you saw your only option at this
point is gotta order the material for
that order the material from overseas
you got it that's what you're gonna do
right I was like screw that and so I
started looking for like weaving and so
I just you know was looking for weaving
like hey hey hey you guys weave can use
a pattern for us yeah hundred thousand
yards you know twelve bucks a yard
no so I'm just looking looking looking
looking and did you ever order any
material I did okay did you you had to
sell keys I mean maybe some money you
had got a Vespa into this thing now
right and I didn't I had I didn't make
it take a paycheck for like the first
two years of business I didn't take a
paycheck maybe three mm-hmm I didn't pay
myself once every dime I just dumped
back in dump back in dump back in
weaving was impossible right you're not
gonna freakin weave material so I did I
imported material
for that first year and we figured out
how to make a key and it was a pain in
the ass and that first week we finished
the week and I called to deco and I said
we made five pairs of pants this week
and he's like not really high production
dude I was just like what am i doing
and I kind of start telling that story
you like legit we're questioning
oh I spiraled down like oh my god you
know you thought you were gonna make 200
G's in the week and he deep pants and we
can you make 5 5 5 pairs of pants I was
just mind-boggling mind-boggling and
Jill was my first teacher she's still
with us today the one you were talking
about earlier did I did not know what to
do I was truly at a loss for I didn't
have anybody did I teach me about how to
manufacture like how you should set this
up I caused the knowledge had
disappeared out of the state it was gone
the folks that used to do that stuff
either they passed or there they moved
on their snowbirds they moved to Florida
or whatever they weren't around so I had
a lot of late nights by myself in my
basement with a glass of whiskey
I started to have that feeling come back
of that like failure feeling and I
didn't know what to do I was like what
did I get myself into you know like what
what are you doing like how do you what
am i doing and then I figured like I
cannot basically like I can't do this
alone
type of situation and in the
conversation with my father-in-law's
like gentlemen I need to talk to
somebody who's like been there and done
that and like done built something from
nothing and he's like Petey's like I've
got a friend that he did some work for
and his bulldozer found lots of heavy
mechanic or fair heavy machinery
mechanic and so we made a phone call to
this guy the john i'll leave his last
name out and john said yeah I'll meet
with Pete he said here's the date and
time meet me at my lake house so I
showed up at his lake house and I sat
down and he shook my hand he said let me
tell you something
you're not fucking special now I'm
already Pete down just I'm using his
words and you're not fucking special
your ideas aren't special and nobody
gives a shit I was like okay
motivational speaker getting after that
Joe nobody gives a shit I said reality
check yeah I was like oh he goes what's
your problem I said man I I we need
money to like music no you don't I said
no we need we need we need money to to
like do this to like learn how to do
this and build this and like make this
happen I need money the capital he goes
Pete were you in the back of your mind
thinking you had good capital investor
right here is it
got a little lake house and maybe this
guy's gonna fill geez at you no no I
wasn't there for financial a financial I
wasn't looking but that was the solution
that you saw you didn't know with him
you just thought I need money for this
thing only solute on it I need money and
as he kind of like beat me down and this
guy ran like a fifty ma I think they're
hundred million dollar company now at
that point I was fifty million dollars
and he was kind of retired and doing
this thing and giving his time to me for
free to help another kid from industry
main succeed
he basically educated me and two hours
educated me and I walked away from that
meeting like with a plan a plan of
action what was like what was the the
big takeaways he told me I need to
basically find out who I was and do a
personality profile and he goes you're
probably what do you say and infj
something like that he like guessed it
or an INTJ I'm not even exactly sure
what it was so I did my personality
profile to find out my strengths and
weaknesses and it was spot-on
I was like holy shit this is that it
like crazy and then he told me you're
not all in you don't really want to win
at this I was like no I do then go all
in how much do you believe in it because
it's a million friggin people like you
he said there's a million people like
you and a million great ideas and less
than 1% are willing to go and chase it
and go all-in and do it are you one of
those people
and if you are solve the money problem
and solve the rest of the problems the
next day I was at the bank signing my
home away with my wife by my side that
she was stoked for a $200,000 loan that
was tough for her two things as you were
saying them there's a big difference you
put them together which is when you put
them together it makes sense but chasing
your goals chasing your dream and being
all in does he's not even the same not
the same things now now if you're all-in
and you have to change it you don't even
know what else to do besides chase it
right but I think some people they they
chase it but they're running like half
speed yeah and I was a half speed here
it's awesome you got to be uncomfortable
that's basically what I took away from
that and he's the one that told me he
said Pete how old do you
I said I'm 30 what's your problem I said
I'll just get John on the podcast at
some point I'm stuck yeah I said I'm
stuck he lose
you got three more chances he's like I'm
60 you got three more chances he's like
if you believe in it and he's the one
that told me everything in life
everything great takes ten years to
build go build it and be committed
because it's got to take ten years to
build it but if you believe in it you
have to go all-in and if you got to put
up your house put up your house you'll
work your way out of it eventually so
that's what I did I followed his advice
and I went all-in he also told me the
moment you stop growing you die he said
if you stop growing you will die the
moment you want to do something
different than what you're doing the
moment your mind wanders to wanting to
be somewhere else
your business also
dies and you need to recognize that and
that first meeting with him was just I
just changed my changed my game and when
I signed my name on that loan when I
signed my home to the bank to receive
that cheque I was laser-focused it's
like being in the woods on an early
morning hunt when it's dark and the Sun
is coming up in the end and the leaves
go right as the Sun hits the leaves it's
the trees and you're waiting right for
the deer for the whatever you're hunting
that's what I felt like about business
at the same feeling you get from that I
felt laser-focused and it's like
everything just opened up like my mind
open like the synapses connected and I
was in like a new per new entre I was
like new and that's what I mean by like
you can't hear I was born an
entrepreneur you're not born an
entrepreneur you need to get punched in
the face and John punched me right in
the nose it was awesome so the next step
is you order some material but that's
not your long-term plan right and and
the next thing you do is you go we got
to make this material we gotta make
ourselves we got to make the material I
had called every used textile company in
the United States every used textile
company to try and find this machinery
we had to weave our own fabric it wasn't
a sustainable model without weaving our
own fabric they're all like just not
gonna happen I'm like what is it to get
set up million dollars right 750 grand
this is to buy brand new losses to buy
in the operational experience in there
and they're gonna send you from the
factory after they build this loom
they'll send you a guy that's gonna help
you run it yeah all set up is that we
just need a million dollars yeah exactly
it's like it's just not gonna happen so
I was like okay in business it's like
boxing like it's like jiu-jitsu it's all
about the angles you know when people
get so stuck on like one angle they
could only see that one angle and I just
had to like either step to the side and
I had to see this angle I knew Maine had
a heritage and weaving I knew there was
weaving here at one point and so I went
back to that same old-timer in Lewiston
Maine who had sold me my first sewing
machine and I sat in his office and I
said you know where there are any looms
he's like what do you mean I'm like a
weaving loom like to leave fabric he
goes get in my truck I get in his truck
we drive up one Street and get out and
this is massive building it's like a I
think total square footage was like 1.5
million square feet mostly abandoned a
few businesses in the front that they've
refurbished and there's a museum there
and then walks in he introduces me to
this woman Rachel and he says Rachel
this is Pete he's looking for a loom and
she goes well follow me she made me sign
a release
we went up these stairs and into this
old mill five and the floorboards the
windows were all broken the Sawtooth
building you know the saw to has mill
buildings and windows were all broken
the wood was all punky in like like a
bent top and splintered you had like
watch where you're walking and there's
this big green nasty thing sitting in
the middle of floor right there in this
whole place
and we walk over to it she's like I need
to get rid of this I'm like this is a
loom she's like you know it's a holy
shit where's the rest of them they ship
them overseas a company in India bought
us bought and bought out the mill and
they shipped everything overseas and she
goes I kept this one I kept it here
because I wanted to put it in the museum
so we didn't lose our heritage
I said can I buy it she said yep I said
how much she said three thousand bucks
I said okay done man and this is it like
I just want to point this out the floor
is all broken the windows are broken and
the Loom is like rusty right oh dude
this town is not like this this thing is
disaster when's the last time it was
used how many years ago Oh
80s it was it's an 83 it's like in 1983
I don't know when the last time it was
used but it hadn't been had any love for
a long long time most of the parts were
stripped off of it it was like a frame
just like an infrastructure I said okay
I'll buy it I'm gonna buy this loom yeah
so you've got to be a little bit naive
to be in business and think you can
accomplish anything that's the bottom
line and now I was pretty pretty driven
and naive to think that we could weave
fabric but I believe we could so she
sold me in and then I called my
father-in-law I said I got a loom it's
on the third floor of this old mill in
Lewiston Maine and we need to get it out
and I got a quote on moving and it was
$25,000 to move it I'm like we're gonna
move it and he's like
okay so I got a bunch of friends we went
up there took nine guys eight hours to
move it from the middle of the floor to
the edge of the building and we had
another friend who had a crane and we
ended up getting it out and onto a
trailer and put it in the factory and
then we were like what are we doing dude
it was awesome it was awesome so that's
where it started
you know it's yeah I always believed
like if it was done it can be done like
if it if you know in Maine we have this
thing like Maine at one point was 90%
filled how to become 90% fields you know
a hundred years ago hands and daylight
hands and daylight right how are these
mill buildings built hands in daylight
that's it
these people they got after it mm-hmm
I mean why because if you don't you die
that's it you're gonna die so you've got
a farm you've got to know how to build a
house you got to know how to start a
fire like that culture of New England is
still rich you know it's still passed
down we burn wood everybody burns wood
we build our own shit you know houses
everything that's what we do why is
everybody saying we can't manufacture we
can't weave we can't cut and so that's
bullshit if they did it we can do it
because they did it with a lot less I
found a guy Lenny when that mill shut
down he had a contract to go over to
Pakistan Pakistan of all places to teach
them how to run the looms that were
purchased and a month later was 911 and
he didn't go
stayed here thank God because he's the
last he's like the last one left that
can actually get this thing going and
make it work again
I asked Lenny how many people know what
you know he said a whole bunch I said
well what's a whole bunch she's like a
five so he Lenny pass his knowledge on
to us weaving pattern making for
textiles and all this stuff and that's a
whole nother story maybe for a different
time but we started weaving fabric and
we became vertically integrated and we
started making the product from rock on
from - what did it feel like the first
time that thing created really like
fabric he must have dude we was freaked
how we were just like he's just like we
had that we had like the path like we
had to make pearl weave and so we did we
made pearl we were like tucked up pearl
we have a part that was like from the
imported fabric is like um we just
picked it apart and let he looked at it
and figured out what size thread you
know yarns and the weight and everything
so we just recreated it and he turned it
on for the first time you know how long
it took to clean that thing 40 man-hours
to clean it like it just need to
cleaning before we did anything cleaning
then we had to buy it all the parts are
machined and just to get it going in he
turned it on for the first time and it
was like and I looked at John my
employee John Lenny and I said holy shit
and then
and there it comes it's just and there's
the pearl we've coming off the loom man
it was so exciting I was like nobody's
ever done this nobody's ever done this
and it was I was super proud I was like
we're we're friggin doing it we are
doing it and then we announced it to the
world we thought we still got a lot of
work to do but uh then we announced it
to the jiu-jitsu world sit sit
I don't even want to tell you the
challenges after weaving how do you
color this though like I was telling you
before when when I was in the seagull
teams in the early 90s we didn't have
the the custom gear right you couldn't
buy this stuff on the internet from
these tactical companies right so we
made stuff and we had we had parachute
riggers which are the people that pack
parachutes but in a parachute loft
you've got a nice medium duty and
sometimes a heavy duty sewing machine
and so we would make our own gear and
and us guys like we would kind of get
into it a little bit and I you know I
had us a lot of seals would have their
own you know sewing machines and you
know you'd make gear and some people
would be good at it
some people get really good at it and I
was not one of those people and it
because you know there's these little
threads and you got to get these things
working right yeah all right stuff yeah
and so and every time I'd like to start
sewing it would just you know fall apart
or like a bird's nest and just mayhem
and when I see like the loom
yeah with it looks like stress
throughout 1 billion winds coming
through these little things and and
they're falling through and then you
look on the other side and all that
craziness there's like these hundreds of
thousands it looks like little pins that
are moving these things that are pulling
apart and raising and then it comes out
the other side and you see this pattern
yeah and it makes me it actually does
stress yeah oh man I can't be in here
for too long because I'm freaking out
just thinking if I get too close to
these things
my my presence will cause disturbances
in the force and things will go wrong
yeah I'm not allowed to be in there for
very long because I'd like I'm not I'm
I've got I've got an issue you know a
subliminal issue with threads and so I
keep my even today on so keeping a
little distance from the machines yeah I
don't want to foul them up you guys have
the magic for that but you see that and
and to even imagine it like you know
again as a novice person working with a
sewing machine as a young kid the how
hard it was for me to do it and then
like I was watching Jill the other wham
wham Wham just hammering you just it's
just such a good craft such a good skill
to have and and just to see the loom in
all those different parts you're saying
yourself well for one thing but good
luck like somebody wants to do what
we're doing
oh-ho yeah do it yeah have fun without
you not happening not happening by the
way we bought the last loom yeah
absolutely and the last bit of knowledge
with sixes which exists yeah man and so
then you know you you take and you start
weaving it and now you start to sell
keys and how's the business going now
now you're able to put on something made
in the USA what a percent and that's
from the dirt to the shirt yeah rod rod
already dirt to shirt right
I mean you killed the finish because the
cotton is coming from Tennessee Delta
region Tennessee spun in the Carolinas
and shipped up to us that's like the one
that's old-school freakin right it is
the way it's supposed to work
that's old-school making shit you know I
mean I talk today a little bit at our
grand opening about like mainers
generations of folks that put their
hands on something right their makers
they need to make something in they're
trying to cross train these people to
type on a computer you know do mundane
office type of tasks filing papers
answering the phone and call centers
these people want to make shit
we're known in Maine for being some of
the best craftspeople in the world the
products that come from Maine are some
of the best products in the world
and to be part of resurrecting that
heritage is it's incredible you know and
it is our ultimate mission you know to
resurrect our heritage and manufacturing
and build old-world level quality
products and stand behind it stitch
every stitch every every yarn in the
weave and that's what we're all about
and that's what Origin stands for with a
little bit more modern look and feel but
sourcing and manufacturing 100% in the
US and I we won't compromise on that
ever like other companies do when they
get greedy and they say well it's time
to look at the numbers it's time to
increase the margins and we gotta import
some of this stuff nope we're not we're
just not doing it she's not happening I
was in Bath Iron Works for the awesome
the christening of the USS Michael
Monsoor obviously named after Michael
Monsoor and it was awesome for me you
know I enlisted in the Navy from that
down in Portland and to come back 26
years later and see what you're talking
about what I knew existed in New England
in Maine and and seeing the pride that
these
you know shipbuilders the ironworkers
that the pride that they took in that
ship named after a saint of a human
being and you know that's one of the
things that I tied to origin because I
knew what you were doing up here yeah
and you know to kind of get to how we
ended up joining forces it's funny
because you know you were just some guy
you know some crazy guy up in Maine in
my opinion that I'd well I'd seen a
couple year videos and I've seen it I
see it dude you know you have the video
that shows you pulling this frickin loom
out of this Factory and I'm just
thinking to myself this guy is insane
and I think I like it and and I had
actually the funny thing is for my gym
in San Diego victory MMA I wanted to
make jujitsu keys in America and so I
was like okay this I I looked around I
find one guy that's doing it it's you
like three or four years ago we went
back and forth on email and you know
nothing ever came of it because I was
busy you were busy and just nothing
happened but I always just remember hey
you know what this guy up in Maine he's
doing what he's doing it the right way
and what happened was the way we
actually got connected was I was on a
Facebook live just talking to people and
someone says what kind of geek should I
get
and I just rattled off I go hey man if
you're gonna be if you need a key you're
starting to Jitsu or you're good at
jujitsu or you just want a good key I go
get a Guinea from origin origin mein
kampf I go get a key from there I go
this crazy guy up there he fixed a loo I
can't say it without laughing he's so
big I'm like he took a loom out of a
flat out of a broken factory and he
refurbished that thing with his team and
they built you know they're doing it
they're building it so if you need a key
and I said I'm trying to talk to this
guy cuz I had I had reached out to you a
couple times of through various even
since the time I asked for four keys
right I'd said sent you an email or
something and I said you know I'm trying
to talk to if anybody knows this guy and
his name is Pete I go tell him I said
what's up
and this this awesome woman that listens
to podcast her name is Sarah Armstrong
and she's super squared away you know
professional with with a big company and
she you know she had communicated me
with the various things over the over
the past year that I've been doing the
podcast and whatnot and for she said oh
I'll take that for action and she
contacted she contacted you called me
it's what she say she just said you
basically she's like have you heard of
this guy
Jaco a Lincoln dude I'm sorry I had my
head up my ass for the last five years
trying to build this factory no factor
and I was like you're like whoo no and
then so you know what do I do I dig I'm
like holy shit like this guy is making
some waves this is awesome and so I did
a little recon and then I reached out
you know after that and and what's
awesome is like well I had no idea what
we were gonna do yeah you know we went
back and forth a couple times on email
and then finally you're like hey man
let's let's go to Skype right let's do
spam because we've been high today you
know do one do something you're like
that one do something you wanna do I'm
like no let's fit you don't figure it
out send me an email about this you're
like how about we do a Skype call so I I
have my meetings like scheduled and I'm
working all day
sure and I blocked two hours I'm like
you know what this is probably gonna
take a while to get this conversation
going about two hours or we're just
gonna get on skype and make this happen
or figure out what we can do so we end
up talking on skype for four hours
talking laughing talking laughs yelling
and yelling after I got off my wife goes
it sounded like you were talking to you
and and it was just you know it was it
was awesome for me it was you know the
things that I believe in as an American
as a person as a New Englander it was
like you had the thing that I didn't
have right like you know for instance
we're we're making things we're building
things but we don't have vertical
integration we don't we didn't we
weren't doing it the way I want to get
it done mm-hmm and so you know I'm
saying hey like let's join forces yeah
absolutely and from my perspective of
course I was like the students for reals
I was like I don't know what to call my
wife I was like man this guy he's on
another level and we we had been like
looking for somebody I remember talking
with the deco and it's like in jujitsu
it's like you've got all these world
champs and then you have like the flavor
of the month guys with like the fancy
Ajit's of stuff and we just it just
never part of our plan to sponsor
jujitsu world champions right because
what we were trying to build is like
much bigger than that it's like man
we've been talking for like a year like
we need to we need to find somebody or
partner somebody with somebody that like
represents origin through and through in
multiple ways this is impossible
you we will not find this person it's
not possible and then we talk we were
talking earlier today this was this is
classic because I didn't remember this
so for those of you that know anything
about negotiation whether you're
negotiating a car purchase or whatever
one of the things one of the tactics of
negotiation is you don't give a number
first so ever if I want if mecca wants
to buy these sunglasses he says how much
are these I don't say they're 10 bucks
because what if he was willing to pay 20
right so so you know if if he says how
much of these I go well you know what
are you willing to pay for him and he
should say well you know I don't know
what are they worth to you
and so
Pete and I had the textbook it was it
was more than that though because it was
it with the strategies it's like what do
you gotta do why you've got a you've got
a devalue or show value so going
backwards well well yeah well yeah yeah
but you know it's it's like you know
back and forth battle battle battle yeah
and then I cave it's a trying to figure
out the value of whatever of something
and and I'm a cold you know what like
you know just give me what if you had to
what would you what would you say a
number of either that and he's you know
he gives me X and and I didn't remember
do it was pretty Taylor that and then I
remembered this week says you know the
values probably X and I went your we
started laughing because we've been
playing the game it was like actually
that is what like both though I think
both of us realized like we were just
let's just get it let's do this but
actually you know I'm busy you're busy
yeah and so we and we actually we both
definitely got along we we I mean I
think both of us felt really solid about
the other person but we didn't quite
figure out how do we couldn't figure out
how to make this work yeah right you
know he's got something that he's put
years of blood sweat tears into I've got
something that I've been doing my my
life has been to get to here and so we
just couldn't quite figure out how this
is gonna work so we just you know we
kept in touch a little bit of
conversation over the next you know
couple months and then I knew I was
going to main yeah you you you can't I
gotta ask you something now you know did
you you knew you were coming to Maine I
knew you were coming to Maine neither of
us like we didn't text back and forth
until the last minute because I knew the
date you were coming to Maine uh-huh did
you were you planning on a meeting when
you came to Maine the whole time I
definitely knew we needed to meet yeah
yeah he's like you were I see
I thought I was putting you on ice we're
both on ice yeah so that was an element
that was like the meeting awesome we met
up in Portland we had dinner we actually
both brought our wives and I my wife is
always too busy to do anything
business-wise with Rena so she was super
stoked to even be around and meet Amanda
and everything and you know you we sat
there
our wives don't even know what they were
doing because you and I were just in the
zone and and at the end of the night we
figured it out and we shook hands in it
and I knew right there we were good we
crafted a deal that was awesome yeah it
was awesome for both of us it was
awesome for everything that will for us
want to achieve and it did he turned
into not even both of us turned into us
exactly and that was awesome and I think
one of the best like lessons learned
from for me what is just an incredible
opportunity that's how I see opportunity
in crafting a deal is making sure that
you're both getting what you want and
you're both a little bit uncomfortable
so that you continue to feel a little
bit of the struggle to make sure you can
take it over the goal line right you're
too comfortable you become complacent
bite off a little more than you can chew
and you're gonna be chewing for much
longer so that's it something was
important it was it's awesome
yeah and so just so everyone knows I
mean I've been saying it like we're
partners you know we're partners with
with the podcast and what what echo and
I have been doing for the last couple
years and what or jibon has been doing
for the last five years seven years five
five years eleven six years ago six
years and and at the end of the night
when we got done eating our steaks in
Portland Maine we shook hands and in
this whole you know you've described it
as like a perfect storm which is what it
feels like to me it is the famous I was
born in gloss
there you go it is the perfect school go
we got we are the perfect storm yeah
and then so that's what's going on is
that you know now we've got this and we
joined forces and that we both
complement each other's you know in
terms of our business we complement each
other's weaknesses in terms of our
personalities we complement each other's
weaknesses and we're and the best part
about it is the whole time that we're
doing it
we're actually laughing our asses off at
each other it has a great time which is
which is what it's all about so that's
where we're at
that's why we're here by the way yeah
that's why we're here by the way if
Farmington Maine in the origin factory
20,000 square feet we're gonna end up
with how many employees in here in a
year how many employees we're gonna have
again Oh probably in a year know 30 40
50 I mean somewhere in there you know
between 30 and 50 that's in a year but
remember this is a start
we're starting and so in five years
we're gonna have a lot of people oh yeah
we're and people ask what are you gonna
make everything and I say we're gonna
make everything everything that I use in
my life I want it made here in America
from the shorts to the hats everything
and that's what we're gonna do
beanies
probably dance bigger hands you know
what how was it a store the other day
getting like a hardware store I'm a big
one where they sell work clothes and I
said to myself you know let's just
because obviously I'm thinking about
this all the time now you know it's hard
to look at a work clothes and you say of
course American workers they would want
to wear american-made clothes wear these
clothes made they're not made here and
then I made America they're not made by
American hands so I think we're gonna be
in a take-no-prisoners scenario and
we're gonna
after it I just kind of take no
prisoners we are going to chase the big
dogs look out look out
listen and look out and that's not
that's not a like an ego thing that's
the truth
yeah listen and look out yeah and like I
said today when when you when you
rekindle the fire of manufacturing and
the you rekindle I mean just talking to
talking to the employees here mm-hmm
this is what they want to do how to
persuade and this is what they're made
to do that's right and like you said
they want to take these things and build
them with their hands who got it and
that opportunity's been taken away in
the last 25 years and we're bringing it
back and that is awesome
appreciate that glad to have you as part
of it all so that's what we did echo
Charles right now my brother speaking of
what we do
sure why don't you do what you do I have
a crafter you asked do you find it
poetic that the origin logo is that
circle remember when you're getting shit
from the politician guys funny you don't
ever thought about that now you have an
origin logo that's a cell it is that
kinda in and of itself is like a circle
yeah it's actually it is a wave it's
it's actually like a rip current wave is
that what that logo it's the it's the
flow the Jujitsu flow the surf flow the
store it's a wave is what that is and
it's breaking symbolic is what I'd call
it
I'll say ironic but it's not ironic
symbolic symbolic it's symbolic
so yeah no one even remembers that I
don't even remember who that politician
was it doesn't matter nope
they're gonna know where that origins is
right in the industry we call that
layers okay
true story anyway speaking of layers got
it and support by the way
support this podcast and yourself or gin
main calm
speak of the devil yeah that's how you
could support yeah so good to know what
do you got jeez so that's the thing from
the beginning people ask what's the key
to get we know we know now 100% now 100%
you know you have like a hierarchy you
know you only have one yeah but you have
multiple selections though yeah so they
do think Edward we're about to like blow
up our manufacturing in this new factory
can grand opening today lots of product
coming right on the G side stuff
ramping things up over the next what
timeframe we've started ramping over the
next four to four to eight weeks let's
say we're gonna be hiring another
sixteen people we put another loom in
the factory so there's three looms now
and we're gonna be weaving ninjas like
like for reals like I don't even want to
elaborate you just come come to Maine
and see yeah anytime in the factory come
check it out I like it when are these
shorts coming out that I'm wearing oh
boy cuz they're straight up my best
shorts investment yeah we're gonna make
it happen
hey I get that all the time hey when is
the you know exercise coming out hey so
knots on you a little bit you know but
yeah these are straight up the best
Shores well it's not actually that hard
for you because people say when's that
next oh you're talking about the the
gear side yeah mesh yeah the merchandise
and ID and I do believe that it might be
a little bit more work on Petes and
compared to on my end a little bit but
hey you know I don't know from from if
you go from like the level that you're
currently cruising at yeah maybe you
both have to travel the same distance
but not just geese right no no sorts of
you know apparel everything is you know
our t-shirts are knit like we have a
partner that knits knits all the fabric
like
six hours away or something everything's
everything's a sourced and made here you
know when we make all our own
compression apparel like cut and sew and
sublimate dye sublimation everything you
say compression apparel yeah I still
called a rash guard it's a rash I know
I'm just just you know what I say
compression appeal because I know it's
not just a rash guard rush card is for
surfing right but but but like the like
like in the jiu-jitsu community don't we
still say yeah I got a new rash guard oh
yeah we're still sick I'm just making
sure because I wasn't like hearing
someone at the gym saying like did you
check out this new compression but in
the weight room there they do say that
yeah right I see like in football
football yeah like you'll see some
company that's advertising compression
I'm like oh you mean a rash guard yeah
call me that you gotta remember like
every textile is different than what
you're used to like like the warp wick
we use our our textile for the rash
guard or tights or whatever else it's
different and you just call them tights
I did because spats I have no idea what
a spaz a out in California it's
definitely called spats
yeah and I don't even know where that
word comes from breath spat I knew spats
is when you tape your ankles as a spy
around the cleat yeah I bet you I bet
you wait did the spats go down your leg
like tight around your foot it was just
tape over you know it just ankles but
instead of your ankles under your sock
tape over your shoe over everything
penis trainer stop doing cuz it's so why
don't we call in compression yeah I'm
gonna be you know earlier we got kind of
like wrapped around or we got
sidetracked
about me being sensitive about something
or not being sensitive tights
you're not down for as a dude right away
we're not wearing tights yeah yeah
compression pants
that's a compression shirt see there you
go compression shirt compression and
rash pants rash guard pants that doesn't
make sense either does it even though
they do prevent rash it's just it's my
sir
yeah or did you two met burn okay you
know why people you know why a lot of
people wear come
Russian pants and compression shirts in
jiu-jitsu the prevention of the disease
the funk yeah right they don't want the
hang horn as I didn't want that that
won't work they don't want you know
whatever mersa yet so people wear that
and you know I the people that I know
that wear it they seem to believe in it
oh yeah just the level of it's not like
like the what's the sun protection
bringing PFS 50 or yeah we're so UV UPF
UPF right UPF 50
there's no anti ringworm percentage
rating right right there's just a
general anti microbial right problem
like but that keeps it from growing in
the material what I'm saying is if you
wear like a compression shirt and
compression pants sure then you're not
rubbing your skin against some savage
that came into the gym with ringworm
right we have less percent rolling with
him too but yeah yeah we're only put a
triangle on his ring more money for
something like this yeah you don't need
that so you don't that's a good reason
to wear compression gear the rash guard
across the board and the rash guards
right there mmm now they're not like the
rash guards you used to the ones you put
on and then they untuck and then you
talked mainly on taki tuck them in
they're designed to stay tucked in so
you can put them on and the way the
fibers flex and Bend with your body it's
not your mothers or grandmothers rash
garden so when when you say tucked in
because you don't really tuck you in a
rash guard right or do you you're
talking about under the gear
yeah oh yeah some places make you wear
rash guard under your geek yeah okay
yeah I think I think it's good to have a
rash guard I knew you I know a lot of
people think that it's not traditional I
mean I miss tradish yeah why do you
think that I like the barrier I like I
like the key how rash or the I like the
barrier between the fabric and the skin
I like the compression because
compression muscle you get more use you
straight performance performance yep god
absolutely like
slides a little bit better on a rash car
than it does your skin once it's all
sweated up and sticky so that's why I
use it and I'm a hairy Greek dude no
that's one of the chest hair you know
yeah neat would be happy if we all wore
rash but she's our black belt at our gym
female and and she is still a girl so
things like chest hairs yeah yeah she's
not happy about a bus sex she begs me to
wear you know something under my geek
she's so far failed but you know the
other thing is you we didn't talk about
origin main calm and supplements yeah
absolutely
so on the body and in your body there
you go
it's it yeah we're gonna put everything
you need on your body and everything you
need in your body krill oil yes really
that's that's the one now it's krill oil
in a super krill oil one of the things
that you know you'll be happy to know
that Pete and I we like to make things
happen and you know obviously I'm a big
fan of krill oil for instance so you
know I was I used to be a fan of white
tea mm-hmm a big fan and I drank it a
lot and eventually I said you know what
I need this jock of white teeth and so I
had a similar thing happen yeah with
krill oil I want to have krill oil good
krill oil so you know what we're making
good krill oil yeah actually we like to
call it Jocko super so aqua super krill
we're making that awesome quality on top
of that we got a little again little
gieux we need joint maintenance right
any chime in is when we are active when
we're training jiu-jitsu when we're
jacking big steel we are tendons and
everything get a little bit store sore
we might not admit to it in public just
like we wouldn't admit to crying right
on a public situation
yeah ever I'm comfortable with my
masculine must be
I'm over here hope nothing like now
don't cry cry my wife says the only time
you cry is babies and belts and someone
gets promoted and someone has a kid
what about weddings no no funerals and
weddings no so we got another another
thing we're coming out with it's a Jocko
joint warfare for your joints go to war
against the pain inflammation go to
mobilization in enemies yeah
I've been kicking it for since we since
we originally formulated and I got the
samples I went on at hardcore and it's
legit
we lost the board I about that I have
like bad back from sports and stuff
herniated discs bulging discs didn't get
surgery severe arthritis I can train
seven days a week if I want to do as a
matter of fact we have our mission
version camp this week train every day
gets every day that's it joint warfare
yep keepin it real well so that stuff we
it's being manufactured we I've been on
the samples for what a month and a half
and now it's been being manufactured in
America check and very close by right by
a partner right and in so it's gonna be
on the website now preorder it and that
way we can get a get a feel for how much
because we've got a bunch coming mm-hmm
we need to figure out how much of a
bunch is that actually means yeah so
kind of like with Jaco white t I didn't
do that I just show the chocolaty for
sale it was gone yeah and then I ordered
some more and and then that was gone and
people were really getting angry because
we you know when you have darker white
tea and then you don't have it all of a
sudden you know you some things start
going sideways yeah absolutely so you
get back straight so anyways you can
check those things out or gin main calm
they'll be there
join warfare you like that don't you I
do yeah
there's there's a layer on there yeah
that's deep deep oh yeah the one person
that's gonna get this layer is Dean
Lister yep yeah yep
Trebuchet I'll leave it at that you know
turbojet yeah yes a lot of moving parts
and a trebuchet yeah how to keep them
greased got to keep that joint sure also
speaking the jack in steel kettlebells
so when we came here we're in Maine
right now with if people haven't
gathered that already up in camp no a
big weight room kind of there's a little
fitness center there yeah first night we
get here one of the guys like hey I
brought my own it kettlebell oh yeah me
too yeah John John yeah it was John yeah
nice yeah honey kettlebell the gorilla
ones I just ordered by the way legit
their ship they're on the way tracking
anyway um yeah that's the good ones you
do kettlebells man I don't you stop
lifting oh that's right stop I did I
stopped lift too massive massive and
bring this up because we talked about
this a pre-recording so you a 250
through right now as we talked about you
used to weigh 285 and I asked this
question and this is a good question
that everybody should kind of hear the
answer to could the 250,000 250 pound
Pete beat the 285 pound Pete in a
grappling match and your answer was 100%
this smaller guy wins yes why is that I
mean lots of reasons you're more
flexible more flexible and better
positioning better escapes because it's
less mass burning less oxygen because
you have less muscle mass and for me I
would wear the 285 version of myself out
so it's I stop and I love lifting
weights I love lifting weights but for
me jiu-jitsu fulfills the void because
it is resistance yeah you're always
working I never feel out of shape well
unless I have too many whoopie pies
what do anything to work out besides you
to do do you run
do you sprint
they just Patricia sue I do
Dean Lister tells me that yeah when Dean
Lister doesn't want to work out doesn't
want to do any veto Sprint's exactly I
do I get I get from jujitsu chuckle
that's one best thing so now you're
supporting his argument now yeah now I
got to deal with that
yeah Robert said you know yeah we'll
talk about something out jiu-jitsu makes
you unathletic oh really that's a whole
other talk interesting and I have facts
on why it makes you on athletic what it
keeps you it keeps your body together
your core together your muscles strong
so what does it do to make you unyk it's
slow movement you slow you start when
you start you do to your body slows down
your mind slows down your muscles slow
down whatever you had for fast-twitch
turns to slow twitch because you're
pulling and tugging and you're moving
slow I used to be able to dunk a
basketball
every dunk so you can touch the rim now
I think we needed I will go ahead and
defend the jiu-jitsu over here on my
side of the table because if you
continue to do cleans and you continue
to squat yeah and you can do use sprints
and mobility drills and a agility drills
you can keep that athleticism I think
you're right I know you're right Jack
that's what I do that's what I did when
I competed I had a strength conditioning
Kojo sprint lift push pull so I guess
big picture is one of those deals where
it kind of confirms the idea that you
don't have to be athletic
to do good in jiu-jitsu generally
speaking on but if you want to do some
kind of athletic competition including
but not limited to jiu-jitsu it helps to
be athletic Jackson steel yeah I'm kind
of glad that you can hit him with that
because when I said I stopped doing like
legs and stuff like that I got a lot of
crap for it yeah by here you know I I I
did a lot of squats in college oh yeah
you put on college football hell yeah I
I'm scared of them I had like hack
squats hack squats man for sure
hey I got mad knees or something bad
back
get in my back yeah last time I squatted
and I hit the floor mmm
right of course bad back that back from
years of major and and personal question
does your ego not allow you to get in
there and do a hundred and eighty five
pounds for some higher reps nope I'd do
that hundred percent but you still don't
like it
I do hack squats I still don't write on
I still don't like him but I mean it's
steel is great yeah that's the bottom
line
yeah it is great I just get a few Jitsu
man I push I do you know every time I
step on the mat that's six ten minute
rounds and I'm trained through the break
so I'm doing 12 minute rounds nice I
make sure to get six yeah and then I get
it as as things free up and my son wants
to lift as he started the summer yeah
I'll get in with him and we'll press
some iron yeah yeah yeah but kettlebells
don't get you that be I mean I'm sure
under certain circumstances you will but
but they aesthetic hang clean you can
clean
snap and the other big thing is when you
like for a kettlebell snatch
it's a swinging motion and when it gets
to the top you have to stop it
right cuz otherwise you're gonna rip
your shoulder out so you have to use all
this whatever that kind of muscle
what is it echo centric or something is
it concentric whatever you got to do is
to stop it at the top yeah you got to
stop it so it's using all these muscles
yeah and make that thing app that's cool
yeah yeah yeah yeah it'll get fun
yeah when you start getting like the
balance and then the looks like there's
some momentum you gotta create momentum
then you got to balance a moment it's
like all this stuff members on college I
said the true true test of how strong
somebody is is I hang clean yeah they
said you could bench a lot you could
squat yeah there's there's a lot of
people yeah there's a lot of things that
you'd say that like for instance you
know it's gonna overhead squat okay you
know like
core you got a guy that can do massive
big weight and orb or medium weight high
reps overhead squat that's legit but on
an inkling you've got to use your speed
also explosive so you can just go
straight to the snatch yeah right
but then again the snatch you need the
balance at the top that's coordination
so and it depends on what you mean by
strong too
so you know how like I guess you know in
in certain circles they call strength
power and strength to power two
different things and it's like okay so
what are you talking about so I dig it
and I agree actually but this is also 20
years ago yeah exactly right you get
another point to consider yeah that's a
really good change rest' yeah agree you
said hang clean right hand clean knees
that's a ritual investor yeah the solid
metric yeah for sure
deadlift another solid metric by the way
yeah raw strength yeah yeah yeah cuz
consider remember be like when you're a
kid or maybe old school kind of
philosophy it's like hey you know you
get the old-timer he's like Oh strong
are you and you're like a real strong
we're so okay
pick that up you know I mean okay you
can't pick it up you're weak you can
you're strong he comes oh yeah yeah yeah
and the the step two is pick it up over
here hey you guys got lift you definite
yeah yeah I don't know just kidding yeah
don't get too nuts with that though
who's that I was just talking to
somebody there's lots of dead lifts mmm
it was it yeah he was a key to a you
know my back and stuff don't get crazy
with deadlifts no but you can talk to
plenty of people that say oh I had a bad
back and I dead lifted and now it's
healed right right plenty of really say
that absolutely crazy with them because
it give you good general strength like
your back too bad because a lot of times
anyway even just even weary in your
cores because when you have like some
core thing on your back or something
when you do stuff you adjust today use
it you know another deadly yeah because
you don't use it anymore so now when you
do something you're grabbing the
cranberry juice from this side you're
gonna put it over here you had a long
floor
cranberry juice in a bottle bro you
shouldn't be that's your body's Way of
telling you don't want that cool right a
man a bigot maybe you're grabbing it
from here putting in the trash
that's why though so you go deadlift not
heavy not crazy just like your body's
like like you need lifting it's like
your body just getting used to it so
boom you're used to picking stuff up I'm
gonna try it do it I like it
try the kettlebells too and if you want
the cool ones when I say cool it's like
you look at them and they're cool
yeah like irrefutable cool on it that's
the ones the gorillas want it actually
they do the gorillas on the air do the
chimp one first yeah about me that I
sent straight to zombies now you're just
super strong there's a woman's always
have my same categories and I figure
what they're all called but like zombie
when I look at the legend versus the
gorillas yeah ones or the primate ones
yeah - to the zombies yeah one of the
ones that look crazy and evil yeah
that's no big collectively know why you
want a zombies technically is so but
that brings up a good point in my
opinion all the different categories
primal bells that's the the chimp the
you know all the things different
zombies all zombies legends werewolf
Cyclops Cyclops like all the legends so
boom pick your category but that's the
cool ones I recommend what else check
them out amen
jump ropes often actually it's kind of
good you go in there and they have all
kinds of workout stuff like stuff you
know all right you know how when you get
into a workout maybe that you you're not
like this but like I got into the
kettlebells and it became fun you know
you know how like if something becomes
fun for me I stop doing it do something
that sucks but they got all kind they
have like the maces and you know all the
workout stuff or whatever anyway that's
a good run on it calm slash chocolate
check out that stuff and man get after
it even if you're getting bored man you
got some interesting stuff to work out
with highly recommend awesome also if
you like these books Pete didn't write a
book way to have you written a book
before I
I wouldn't be surprised I wrote a long
ass paper yeah when I couldn't sleep
over the last year but yeah Auto book so
yeah a little bit different but anyway a
lot of times jock will review books on
this podcast people like to get them if
you're one of those people out there go
the website chuckle podcast comm section
books from the podcast click through
there to get the books that's a good way
to support takes you to Amazon or if
you're doing any other shopping do it
through there big support small actions
more action big reaction nice also
subscribe to the podcast and Google Play
we still feel the need to say that yeah
because what some people aren't
subscribed in the event yeah you know
it's it I guess it's just our guest my
guess there's probably hypothesis
speaking as my hypothesis what I'm
saying there's probably a marginal group
who's like a who's Jocko I heard him on
Joe Rogan or I don't know I seen him on
whatever I'm gonna call me listening to
the podcast that's like okay cool listen
to let me listen to another one okay
cool
maybe I'm not down you know he's kind of
weird or just whatever they don't
understand like oh I can subscribe to
this but I can just get it'll tell me
when it's coming right cuz a lot of
people don't listen to podcasts yeah I
got a question for you about that have
you thought about cuz you this is number
90 yes you thought about breaking the
podcasts into categories to speak to
your audience because you cover such a
broad audience
when you say breaking them you mean just
another section like cut them up
no no no the full podcast but I think
you where you're covering books where
you're talking about this yes where
you're interviewing somebody breaking
them up that way yeah they are I think
cuz there's no linear right you don't
have to listen from right right up to I
recommend when someone says hey you know
I just heard your podcast I heard
I heard I just isn't that podcast you
just put out I want to listen to the
rest of them should I go backwards
should I go forwards and I tell people
start at one and and most of the people
that I talk to that are into the podcast
they're like that's the right advice
tell people start at one if I said Jocko
I want to listen to your real
business-related podcast rights
I couldn't could I do that or no what we
are going to do and I have this in the
background going into something that
I've been trying to get done for a while
is we're gonna kind of archive where
you're gonna be able to maybe figure out
oh I want to listen to business boom and
here's a podcast there's a section now
whether or not we like chop them up and
put them into one group not yet not yet
yeah yeah I mean it you're yeah it's not
organized we'll say but you know it's
one of those things you gotta manually
look you know cuz it'll say what it's
about
in fact the pipe it's straight up by
timestamp yeah you can kind of do it
that way but no not organized like if
you're and it makes sense though because
if we're talking about a book and people
like what love World War two love yeah
yeah yeah and they can just get after it
and then maybe you know just idea good
idea Pete
big-time oh yeah subscribe that's a good
one
if you haven't already how about that
you haven't already subscribe that's a
good one also YouTube subscribe to it
Allen yeah that one's a little bit more
like make sense to be like hey subscribe
yeah and the big thing that you might
not know is if you're not subscribed to
YouTube there could be things that are
not in the podcast yeah so let's say you
like the podcast you're listening to it
and you go yeah well I've heard all the
podcast I don't need to get YouTube
you're wrong
yeah because there could be things
released into the YouTube that have not
been released
yeah for instance deleted scenes deleted
scene which is us talking off the record
about things like people that have
certain you know what issues okay okay
nothing bro lack of squatting issues
yeah and I said I'd stop squatting
because of actually the technically the
story
stop squatting because my wife said hey
your legs are like real big and it looks
weird that's funny because my wife said
you're starting to get an old man but I
don't like it though I'm squatting like
kettlebell swings boom yeah a regular
one they say that the the the regular or
the Russian kettlebell swings
either way
yeah the deleted scenes that's what he
was giving me shit about because I stop
squatting actually did stop squatting I
stopped squatting like hardcore legs you
know I'm saying the point is is you stop
squatting on there excerpts too you know
like let's say you're like hey I liked
that part and people still email me
about that by the way or they're like
hey what was that part or what episode
was that from that part where whatever
so instead of having to scour zooms in
just share that excerpts easy to find so
yeah that's gonna subscribe to youtube
also choco is a store it's called
Jacko's door jockle store calm guess
what's on there everything potentially
everything but as of right now there's
some shirts on there women's stuff on
there patches on there you know you put
them on your hat
interchangeable velcro patches if you
all rash guards awesome so now they have
two options huh mm-hmm Jocko rash guards
get after it
trooper darkness rash guards and origin
rash guards yeah just like that the
selection just that's my wife right yeah
and eventually they're gonna be and this
will be will it'll all be kind of melt
together we have one gate vast option
place to just go in it's basically gonna
be a melting pot of Awesomeness yes yeah
but you simple indeed yeah all that so
and some hoodies on there
yeah I think we should consult no I'm
gonna tell you I already know what he's
gonna say he's from Hawaii what you want
a lightweight hoodie No so he made
hoodies and I'm from New England it's
always like oh you make a hoodie you can
wear it in like a full fledge Arctic
storm and you better have a heavyweight
Cody so his his hoodies are light
therefore they're cool for SoCal yeah
they're good for Hawaii if you even have
hoodies in Hawaii they're like a fall
hoodie I guess that and even that's like
my guess I don't know that's why I'm
saying we should confine his is like his
consultation things when I consult him
like hey it's it's like mixed in with a
scolding so you might get the scolding
first then I want to make a really
really bad ass flat locked hoodie to do
it what is the fun wait wait a sec flat
seemed hoodie how could we possibly do
that where are we gonna get someone that
knows how to make a flat lock through
awesome badass hoodies oh wait Proctor
that's right that's good stuff also hmm
psychological warfare previously few
minutes ago we talked about joint
warfare for joint generation is
summation tation all that stuff overall
real generates generally supplementation
for your body yeah sometimes you need
supplementation for your mind or your
mind yes full-on so in your campaign
against weakness psychological weakness
you know you're trying to get up every
day right stick to the diet can that
help me with eating multiple whoopie
pies ah yes yes yes yes actually there
isn't a specific catalyst you and I'm
definitely interested in that because
that spend my one struggle as a human
what is a whoopie pie a whoopie pie is
like cake and with cream right yes yeah
so yeah sound like a Fig Newton
commercial cuz a Fig Newton is if you
put those two next to each other they're
in different planets
exactly Newton's were healthy though
allegedly giant blocks of sugar cake
which is pretty much
which is why my homie over yeah I'm
single-parent family for kids we were
fighting over the food in the house dude
I've never broken out of that and the
whoopie pie needed for you to break you
don't weekend weekend worse we can
introduce you to a track called
sugar-coated lies really yeah yeah I'm
very interested yeah we'll get you on
the show guys yeah week there yeah and
we think it'd be like Jocko yelling at
you like don't whatever but it's a
pragmatic explanation of what your mind
is doing right now and what it shouldn't
be doing and what it should be doing
like okay in psychological warfare that
can help yes basically it's a you
mentioned that it's an album isn't oh
yeah yeah it is an album with track on
iTunes choco treasure I tuned Amazon
music like all these things yeah mp3 yes
and you know what you you probably
sitting here thinking like okay that
that's a neat little idea that you know
echo came up with and made jock will do
this and cool that album number one
spoken word album on iTunes for I don't
know I lost like like 38 straight weeks
you're kidding number one that's yeah
badass no big deal you know yeah I know
it's awesome and I will say that when
echoes like dude you just kind of you
know just just you know these things
that I'm asking you about you got it
just like you know hammer and I'll just
record it yeah it's basically like okay
so I used to have this thing used to not
any more have this thing where you know
and you're like okay I'm working out
this day they say you know I'm just do
this and when it comes time to work out
and I'm at my house now so I'm like ah
maybe I'll dude I meant to do it at noon
I'm do it tonight I don't feel like
doing around do it tonight and then you
know accountability yeah nobody's
watching
yeah you can do what you want yeah when
I feel like it a little bit marching
some coffee meat whatever it's right
outside you know can I totally get it
yeah and that that it that night turns
into he'll do it tomorrow
so you basically turn a workout day into
a rest day and this helps you turn on
your motivation to get it done yeah and
it's again it's not like a motivational
thing it's like okay this is it's jaakko
saying it so okay there's that but it's
like it's saying okay this is what's
going
right now this is what you're thinking
right now this is what you shouldn't be
thinking right now that's what you
should be thinking right now okay there
you go
go that's right it's the thing that I
find about them is because it is me
talking yeah
I find it they're they're very very
tight arguments yeah get done listening
in you go you know what man I still find
a little hole in his argument you know I
think there's one sugarcoat this one
won't be buys it not gonna be ya know
you like to know what this is a big deal
yeah and I'm sitting there will be
buying a side yeah you know you might be
the ultimate test case yeah
I will be the ultimate I don't care I
don't care who's around me Ben if like
I'm saving for sure we will travel in
the other day what I get sweet tea dan
why sugar sugar but I love baklava yeah
bro I'm we're gonna ruin you know your
mom is I know I can tell ya she's you
know you're like hey you want to try
these things and I know what it is and
and you said man you gotta try the
sparkle on my mom's no bro I know it's
sweet right you go yeah yeah it is my
girls never had Spartan baklava yeah I
was like you know you know no big deal
and you know we've been lately been
saying like you know the discipline
won't allow it that's when we when we
you know maybe see each other maybe
taking a path that we shouldn't be
taking it we're going off V path and on
to the path of weakness you know it
might be like hey hey echo you know
that's cool and everything but the
discipline won't allow that aw man
so that's awesome you know yesterday you
know you're dangling this custom
homemade baklava and my mom's there and
your mom's there we like that and I know
I can see her she looks like she arrived
from Greece three days ago to make the
baklava okay I'll have one right so I
had one yesterday and then the
discipline wouldn't allow anymore
today I had nine of them I had three of
them sugar-coated lies baklava
my mom is gonna get called to make
baklava yeah in baklava pretty sure we
got they will serve those
yeah but yeah but keep in mind though
with these tracks you got to be on that
path though it's not like you're like
hey I eat too much let me listen to this
track it's not that it's okay my plan is
to straight up clean up my whole shit
like my plan is so you've already found
a bit of motivation yes yeah you're
motivated you're on the path already but
it's on the weakness moments the moments
that we can see like okay I'm gonna I'm
gonna rest today and you know whatever
is that kind yes I did that I do we all
do we all do
that's that's probably why a lot of
people get that album yeah with tracks
you don't I do I'm like you rat you know
what I used to do no no what I would do
is this and be like especially when I
was training for competition I'm going
to eat this whoopie pie I would eat it
and I would run two miles yeah I was
burning it friggin right yeah yeah I'd
do that too like yeah like it normally I
try and preempt weakness with hardcore
exercise are you paying by the way mmm
often mitigates yeah it takes like a
like oh I want to have a mint chocolate
chip milkshake cool I can have a mint
chocolate chip milkshake as soon as I do
30 clean and jerks okay that I could I
look at the bar down I can do that and
that's cool but then what by the time
you get done you know what I didn't want
that thing yeah I infused my brain with
discipline from the bar they went from
the bar into my hands and into my brain
yes I know great idea yeah in the
simplest one was very active yeah
burpees like okay you know what I can
have this if I do auger burpees that
takes less than 10 minutes we had this
thing the other day and I talked about
it my freezer in my house broke and so
we had I have an RV and our frozen food
was in the RV refrigerator and I wanted
some ice cream and then I was like ah
you know it's all the way up the other
thing and I said my god what a lazy
loser you don't even deserve ice cream I
didn't have it yeah because I said
you're a pathetic if you're actually
questioning whether it's worth it
you don't need this at all in any way
shape or form if you were thinking it
wasn't worth 27 steps to get to the RV
grab the mint chocolate chip Breyers ice
cream bring it back down
scoop it into a bowl let it melt a
little bit and then just sit there and
yes so good you like a little melt to
the ice cream just a little melt like it
sighs if I return gains Bowl no have you
ever heard that term gains ball it's
it's you you basically take ice cream
and you put milk in it yeah Gaines Bowl
that's what I did yeah yeah let's let's
all detach right now and consider what
we're talking about right now the
pleasures of Gaines ball
the problem is chocolate-chip ice why
would walk barefoot and two feet of snow
to that friggin RV yeah this guy no he
was that in a compliment that it is that
a negative or positive no yours is worse
it's weird because you have a better
result but your disc or your path is
where cuz he was like hey I'm gonna be
weak I have this 100 a week to be weak
that was him that day yeah but you could
that's rationalize because the end you
know the means in the end yes situation
thing is I actually embarrassed myself
yeah yeah it was I just you made myself
when I said I can't believe I'm even
questioning the fact if I would take 27
steps to my RV ice cream the fact that
I'm even thinking that way I don't you
deserve I should haze myself right this
is ridiculous and pathetic and just stop
and so yeah I didn't get the ice cream
that night but the mint chocolate chip
ice cream for sure is is a real thing
it's even but it's my favorite flavor
yeah my flavors although when I was in
Montana moose tracks lose tracks English
track moose tracks that's the other
that's the other okay I'm not gonna you
know I understand and I saw it and I dig
it but it's just it's very surprising
that you hockey okay in this trio you
you can claim by the way you can close
the Moose track with a scoop of mint
chocolate chip I've never done that the
rounds deranged it's like it would push
me over cheese cheese and wine
geez closes just a finishing touch is
that what you do is that what we should
do now and one of my buddies in the in
the jeans is a awesome guy
badass wrestler wrestled was a champion
wrestler in college and was on the
Olympic team didn't compete for variety
reasons that I want to talk about but he
was friends with Dan Severn you remember
Danny oh yeah yeah early us and so hey
ed so I don't know why this just came to
my mind oh I know I did so he would say
they knew each other they were friends
and whenever he'd see Danny Severn Danny
Severn was a heavyweight hmm and this
buddy of mine was cutting weight you
know he was a big guy he was like
whatever wore like 200 pounds we had to
cut to 190 whatever and he would call
Dan Severn a potlikker
meaning like mean like your your just
your guy that's over there you're eating
everything when you get done eating your
liquor the pot right picture you with
the smile you got to the other that bowl
you're like oh I'm getting the the rest
of this mint chocolate ice cream is
getting into my belly now my my my kids
have followed the path of my wife and
they'll come up to me when I'm eating
junk food and they'd be like dad you got
boobs
dad I'll just grab them that fat on my
guts you don't need that
oh they're brutal day it's kind of sad
yeah it is I'm surprised you're not
sometimes like four pounds I should be
actually but we say that's the freedom
part but the thing is you gotta be on
the path right so like yes you know how
this discipline comes freedom right so
you know you grab the ice cream yeah
I had to pull that one yeah for the
first time I was I don't I was at a
little like family get-together and
there was a but it was a birthday party
for a friend of the family blah blah
blah and there was a grandmother there
so a grandmother form of these kids I
had a birthday party bah bah bah so and
she's a German woman mm-hmm and you know
she kind of knows what's going on a
little bit with the game with what's
going on
and so I'm sitting there and there's
like a um you know straight up this is
rough you know the ice cream cakes you
can get a mint choc do ice cream shake
so the cake is a mint chocolate chip ice
cream cake hakka to a right that kids
yeah
so I'm talking to a potlikker yes so so
I'm like okay you know what I'm gonna
get some of that mint chocolate chip ice
cream it's got those what I don't even
know what it is those little block like
crumb things that capers in there too
we're talking this is a situation needs
to be you know we need to get in on this
thing real quick it is a little bit
melted so it's soft
so anyways I'm cutting a piece of the
cake not a big piece not a small piece
but you know like a medium piece getting
on my plate stick my fork in and this
woman this German woman who's super cool
she's like I thought you were about
discipline and I was like dang and she
called me out and I looked at her said
you know what I have the discipline and
that allows me to have freedom sometimes
to eat mint chocolate chip ice cream
cakes which I'm about to do thank you
this is the freedom part but like I said
you got to be on the path you got to be
in the game you can't just be like this
is the freedom part every single day no
doesn't work doesn't work that way also
jakka white tea you can get that you
know what it does if you're gonna start
deadlifts and again you should get drink
a little bit more jock or white tea
because it will increase your deadlift
to 8,000 pounds this is proven proven
across the board I'm on it everyone
books I got some books if you want to
get them extreme ownership book about
leadership book about combat leadership
you can get that you can get it free
yourself and you can get it for your
team and you can get it for above and
below you in the chain of command it's
gonna make your life easier when
everyone's on board if you got kids or
you know kids you can pick them up a
book called way of the warrior kid and
what that's gonna do is gonna lay out a
path actually yes a path yeah that a kid
who doesn't have a path
kids don't have a path the book will
give them the path and the path leads
them to being stronger smarter and
better so my daughter read it she loved
it that is awesome and she is an
individual and she speaks her mind and I
was like Chloe no really what did you
think cuz I love that book and she came
up and she wanted you to sign it yes she
wanted me to get her copy back at home
today because I feel that we will get it
tomorrow yeah I'll get it tomorrow
awesome that's yeah I appreciate it in
and yeah straight up like when you ask
kids how did you like it which I always
ask kids how they like it and because
you know kids like you said kids are
gonna tell you the truth yeah yeah and
so so far I have not had a kid go
yeah marginal marginal marginal all
right you kind of missed the mark but
you know yeah entertaining not that but
you know whatever
they should make that shit into a movie
or something oh they're gonna make it
into a movie um also another book coming
out October 17th discipline equals
freedom Field Manual that will also show
you the path it's going to show you the
it's gonna show you one path the path of
discipline grab that book if you need
help with your business I have a
business called echelon front with my
brother Leif babban and he was we worked
together in the SEAL Teams Battle of
Ramadi
we took the lessons that we learned we
wrote that book extreme ownership and
the reason we wrote that book extreme
ownership was because we had people that
we were consulting asking us to write
down the lessons learned so there it is
if you want us to come work with you
it's Lafe babban me
JP Danelle Dave Burke you know who they
are
email us info at echelon front comm also
the muster September 14th and 15th in
San Diego California we could throw out
the like game-changer which definitely
has been said about it but I'm
say this it's not this fantasy game
changer thing it's actual pragmatic
tactics and strategies that you can use
as a leader as a follower in business
and in life come to the muster in San
Diego
September 14th and 15th you can register
for the for the muster at extreme
ownership calm also until the muster if
you want to communicate with us you can
do that we can all be found on something
that we talked about earlier tonight the
interwebs Twitter Instagram and that's a
zebu ha echo is at Echo Charles Pete is
at origin we're talkin Instagram are we
talking Twitter Instagram where you at
origin USA Twitter where you at at
origin be jayjay as in Brazilian Jujitsu
awesome I am at Jocko willing if you
want to hit us up you can hit us there
echo any clothing song clothing clothing
clothing Fox we got a lot of clothing
thoughts in it yeah closing thoughts not
that fit Pete the man great to finally
meet you in person and I appreciate that
right on thank you guys
man I'm honored to be at the table with
you both and just mad respect for
everything you guys do like why just
glad to be here with you and experience
this also I want to thank my wife Amanda
for putting up with my crazy shit and
midnight ideas and allowing me the
flexibility to live this life which is
important in relationship and my kids
Keegan and Chloe who are the ones that
work for every day day in and day out
that family
good things coming yeah well for me you
know I wish I would have met you 20
years ago for whatever reason I didn't I
wish I would have met you 10 years ago
for whatever reason I didn't met you six
months ago and just looking at what
you've done I'm telling you and if I
haven't made it perfectly clear today
what you've done to this point already
is incredible
I don't I don't even it's the the
possibilities of you pulling off what
you've already pulled off is incredible
and what's what's cool is it's like when
a when a when a space shuttle takes off
the hardest part of the journey is that
first part getting breaking away from
gravity of Earth and what you've already
done you've cleared the gravity of Earth
and now you're on track and it's it's
you know just nothing but respect for
what you did I know that you have used
your hands to make this happen your mind
to make this happen and I just respect
everything you've done so far
talking to the team here and the
attitude that they have everybody has
that attitude and and just for me to
come in and be a part of that is just
outstanding I look forward to being a
part of this team I look forward to
getting to know the team when I can come
up here which is hard but to see the
people on this team is is phenomenal and
I can't wait to see where it goes so
thanks for coming on and this is
guaranteed to not be the last time and
of course to the military folks overseas
right now thanks for allowing us to make
this podcast we could not make this
podcast without your service and
sacrifice to the police and all law
enforcement to firefighters EMTs and
other first responders again you allow
us to make this podcast and we are
thankful
or it and finally and of course to the
working class of America thanks for
doing what you do day after day working
sweating bleeding building calluses
while you build our great country thank
you for holding the line and thank you
for getting after it
so until next time this is Pete Roberts
and echo and Jocko out